yeah you're now live chair
thank you very much tom well good
afternoon everyone and thank you for
attending
this afternoon's meeting of torres
district council's external and overview
scrutiny committee
i'm sorry we're just a few minutes late
um it's modern technology
uh we're just trying to um get used to
all the numbers so i do apologize
if if there's been a slight bit of
confusion before we started the meeting
um but we're all here now it looks like
pretty well so grateful and thank you
for all attending this afternoon
we begin meeting with the agenda
item number one mary can you do uh the
roundup and apologies for absence please
chair i have no apologies for absence i
will just run through the register if
that's okay though
please yeah counsellor cuddle honking
present councillor ford
no he's not present council harding
here councillor hawkins
no not president councillor langford
present
councillor leather
no not prison
councillor mackenzie yeah
councillor newton yes mary i'm here
councillor pennington i'm here mr topham
tom i have just had a note come up on my
pc
from barbara shaw saying she's waiting
to be let in so she must be waiting
at the other meeting get hold of her
okay
may i go forward mary or shall we wait
for barbara to join us
um we can probably go forward because
we've got the minutes
if we go through the minutes now uh
we'll go to
uh agenda item number two
and that is minutes of the meeting of
the 20th of january
pages three to eleven i will go through
them first of all
for accuracy anything that is recorded
that is
felt is not correct please let me know
so i'm going at the bottom of the page
but page three
i see no blue hands page
4 5
6 7
8 9
ten
eleven and eleven's just got the note
that we finished at five to nine
on page eleven so i
am happy to propose this as a record any
second or please
yeah okay yep simon is that you yeah
that's me
thank you simon uh so proposed from the
chair
seconded by christian newton that this
is adopted as a correct
record of the meeting of the 20th of
january
shall i take the recorded vote yeah yeah
i think we have to
yeah if we can councillor hankin or
councillor ford for councillor harding
or is councillor hawkins with us yet
no he's not present he's trying to get
through on the other one i think tom
uh councillor langford for
councillor leather or councillor
mckenzie
four councillor newton
or councillor pennington four
mr topham
mr tobin
[Music]
thank you pardon four thank you chair
that's unanimous
thank you very much indeed for for that
it is
yeah uh just to go through any matters
arising anybody want to raise any
matters arising
because i have just a couple on the page
about
the recommendations at the presentation
from
cab and ttvs
and encompass um one recommendation
didn't go forward
because our local central government
doesn't
uh forward i think i saw make sure i got
the right page here
bottom of page seven that the full
council write to the local mp
or central government to encourage them
um
to support levels of district and county
funding for these voluntary services
now then county was already funding as i
understand it
and district we did send forward on our
second motion
to the meeting of the 20th of january so
that actually didn't go forward
to the local np at the time okay so that
was what didn't happen
but the further motion went forward to
community resources i think is page 26
uh or what through the full council on
the 26th of
january anybody any other matters
arising
no blue hands thank you
then we move on and we go forward then
to public participation i have no
notice of public participation anybody
uh uh speaking tom or mary
contribution today none at all so we go
to agenda item number four which is the
action list
on page 12. just two items on the action
list
and i think they've both been completed
any questions from the committee on that
action list
no so we dealt with like dead item
number four
so we go then to uh declarations of
interest
sorry yes i should have said at the
beginning i haven't read out the uh
rules of um
engagement um that i was given to read i
i take it you're happy as a committee we
proceed forward without going through
that long procedure and he'd be sure
otherwise i'll get tom to read them to
you
i do apologize for not reading them at
the beginning no
red hat you're happy that we proceed yep
good fine so that dealt with that so we
go back then to decades of interest
agenda item number five
um i have uh you you all know the
procedure from that point of view
uh and uh you know what the appropriate
time to make notice uh a giant
agenda item number six agreement of
agenda
items part one and part two new part two
so there's nothing there urgent matters
brought forward with permission of the
chair
just to say um i've agreed with helen
smith that
we have a a a presentation also of the
devon home choice
that will follow um barbara shaw the
chief executive
officer of westwood housing so that will
come into the agenda at that point
therefore it gives me great pleasure to
welcome from westwood housing
barbara shaw our chief executive or not
our chief is a
chief exec of westwood housing um
kindly sent forward a lot of information
and took
some of our questions and i asked you
barbara if you will lead us
in the presentation of westwood housing
please
well thank you very much councillor
pennington and i'm delighted that devon
and home choice are coming to talk to
you afterwards because i am not an
expert on that but we do have
a very good relationship with them so um
thank you for inviting me i'm um chair
of westwood noche i'm ceo
of westwood housing and have been for
nine years now
very happy to answer your questions as i
go along if you have any
but as you say councillor pennington and
i've sent in my q a where some of you
would ask me some questions and i hope
that
we provided you with sufficient
information on that q a sheet
thank you pleasure before i begin as
well just to let you know
um i i meet regularly with your chief
operating officer every six months
that is steve it used to be jenny and my
colleagues work with a variety of teams
within tdc including planning enabling
and the benefits team so i'm going to
give you a brief overview of westwood
looking at our senior management because
it has changed significantly certainly
since i first arrived
our strategic plan our priorities for
the next five years
and then just talk about development and
finish with where we are
with our carbon zero journey so we could
just move the slide along
so just so that you are familiar with
westwood
we operate across devon and cornwall we
have
7536 homes
and employ 290 people
so all of the activity that we we do
through employment procurement
arrangements
development and by working with key
partners such as west country credit
union southwest water
and devon and somerset fire service we
create around
28 million pound of social value each
year and we think that's really
important
the westwood board a bit like yourselves
is responsible for the strategic
direction of the organization
and over the last six years it's been
totally refreshed
due to our tenure rules and it
compromises
of ten members and the chair of the
customer senate joins us for
all meetings our chair is brian ed
whose experience is predominantly in the
nhs
our senior independent director or
deputy
is francis west who has worked in the
armed forces and local government
and will patterson is chair of audit and
assurance
and spent his career at lloydsbank
the executive is a much smaller team and
consists of three people
and we hold portfolios so jan montague
is portfolio holder for housing support
services
and hr paul bayern portfolio holder
for finance property and procurement
and then i'm responsible for development
corporate services which are i.t
communication and business support and
business transformation
and to help us deliver our portfolios
we have four operational directors if we
just move on
look who could click on oh there they
are sorry so we've got hayley austin you
might have to click again i think
no okay hayley austin she's on my left
hand side in the pink shirt
she is our housing director rinshawi in
the checked shirt
and the only man on the slide is our
property director
rachel searle with the longer blonde
hair
is our development director and then we
have
dye sterling chow who is director the
support services
and these are your main contacts because
i would presume that if
one of your constituents come to you
then clearly
it's an issue that has to be dealt with
at a higher level and all of their
details are in the q a
for you so if we could just move on i'm
now going to talk briefly about our
strategic plan
so our strategic plan was reviewed in
2019
ready for 2020 and covers a five-year
period
up to 2025 and during the summer
of 2020 the board reviewed the plan
to ensure that it was still relevant in
light of covid
and i'm glad to say it was so
westward's overall strategic business
plan is made up of a number of documents
and you can see those on the right hand
side
and together they ensure that we deliver
our objectives
and remain a robust and financially
strong organization
and those documents are our strategic
plan
the 30-year financial business plan
budget and our annual corporate plan
which outlines our key strategic
projects for each year
our purpose for the 2025 strategic plan
remains the same as previous and if we
can just move on
our purpose is quite simply
providing homes and supporting
communities
after consultation for our last
strategic plan
we slightly revised our values and if we
can click on
and those values are be proactive
always engage and show integrity
um these were tweaked and similarly
with our objectives what our customers
colleagues and stakeholders told us
was that we needed a specific objective
that focused on customers
and that we needed to shorten our
objective on finance so here are
objectives you can read them i don't
need to say them
but that one about our customers is
really important to us
so if we could move on
so within our strategic plan we
obviously outline what our priorities
are
so our priorities over the next five
years
obviously we want to build 700 homes
that's what we've got capacity to do
but this time we really want to focus on
our heartlands
which are tour bay toric and plymouth
we need to begin our journey on
decarbonisation of our homes
which as you will know is a legal
requirement and must be reached by 2050.
we want to engage more with our
customers on services
and that has commenced and during the
summer along with
them customers and a consultant we
produced a customer engagement strategy
and plan plus customer standards
and this month we also appointed a
customer insight and engagement manager
and we want to ensure that our homes are
safe and secure
and that's especially so in light of the
grenfell tragedy
which now happened gosh it's three and a
half years ago almost so that's that's
that's a long time and finally we want
to continue
with our digital program evolve which
will take advantage of technology
to make us more efficient but that will
mean that we can direct our resources to
those customers
who really need our support so
if we could move on and we can be a
little bit more specific
about our current homes in torridge so
within torridge we have 1884 homes
and of those 1518
are general needs homes and are and have
a social rent
58 homes are affordable and their rent
is based on an 80
of market rent and then we've got 243
homes
that are for older people and are a
social rent
and then finally we do have 65 shared
ownership homes
um at the start of the panda pandemic
um sorry could we go back we're not
so at the start of the pandemic we had
um 71 calls from tenants in towards
with concerns about their rent
and their home and we were able to give
them support and advice
and at the moment our current reviews in
college
are at 1.3 percent of our gross annual
debit
and that translates into about 473 cases
with an average debt of 240 pounds
that may seem high but actually that is
relatively low
compared to other areas that we work in
and when we've analyzed that from our
perspective we think that's
there are a number of reasons for that
one of them
rents are lower in torridge compared to
elsewhere
your rents are also weekly which helps
people to manage their money better
and a higher percentage of customers
within territories
claim housing benefit and the general
age group tends to be higher
that's not to say that it's still not a
real issue
but there are some reasons why when we
look at our overall
areas 1.3 is an extremely good place to
be in
especially when you consider the times
we are going through
more detail in the q a um and i've also
explained in there
how we're supporting customers who are
in arrears
but just to give you the keys of
headlines
at the beginning of the pandemic we made
a westward assurance
that if any customers fell behind with
payments because of coronavirus
they would not lose their home we've
made collection of income
much more personable we used to send out
lots of letters we've got rid of the
letters
and now our staff talk to customers
directly they get weekly phone calls to
see how they're getting on
with paying their rent etc and we also
have a number of financial inclusion
officers
who work with our customers to help them
ensure
that they're claiming as much benefit as
they're entitled to
um and that's been an absolutely
essential service especially at the
beginning of the pandemic
so that's toridge in terms of where we
are with some of our customers and how
we
are working with them through the
pandemic
so our now now go on to development so
we can have the next slide
um and uh this is one of our schemes
this is put in place um you may know
that as stuckley road
and we've got 15 homes here in total
seven are for shared ownership and
they've either been sold or
are reserved and we've got eight homes
for social rent
and the final homes will be handed over
um
this month but um you're probably more
interested in what we've got in our
pipeline so if we go to my next slide
thank you um so within our pipeline
which covers from now until 2025
we've identified 163 homes
within towards some of those schemes are
what we call
land lead opportunities and that means
that we own the land or we purchase the
land
so we own the land on newton road where
we have a scheme that is nearly
completed
other schemes we are looking at through
section 106 agreements
which is where we work with a developer
and
i'm sure you all know but you know under
those schemes a developer is obliged
to build a number of affordable homes
unless there is a viability issue
but again those those um rules are about
to change over 106s which you may or may
not be aware of
and it's going to be done slightly
differently
with yourselves taking a role in um
deciding what happens with regard to
social housing
um all of these schemes are at different
stages at the moment
some of them are actually in situ some
of them are about to come to fruition
and others we're still running them
through our financial models to see if
they're fireball
but certainly as i've said put in place
is due to handover
this month newton newton road will hand
over the second week of
april and bridgeworld goes to planning
this month
so i hope that gives you um some idea of
what we're planning on
doing over the next five years and there
is still capacity within our um
our development programme if we identify
more schemes within the torridge area
so just going on to my next slide
thank you i'm sorry the pictures aren't
great but
as you can imagine it's been difficult
to get pictures
during this period and when we have been
out clearly the weather has not been
brilliant
but just to let you know newton road
we've got 26 rented homes there
um due to hand over second week of april
there are 24 one and two bed flats there
which i know people did ask about um
flats for young people but hopefully
that that shows you that we do where we
can
build those flats and where there is
demand we've got
two three bed houses and then we've got
five shared
ownership three bed homes and those have
all been reserved which is is absolutely
great news
so that's our development program i
should pause there
just in case anybody has any questions
i see no blue hands what i got a hand
from
counselor tony inch oh sure hello tony
thank you hello barbara long time though
yes long time
just just to go back to one of your
slides there the boat the
development and the hoses that you
intend to build
i see i notice on there that there is
one for bowed and green
16 houses mixed development
is that on the play area because um i'm
quite concerned about that actually
i don't think that's been decided but if
it were tony we would consult with the
local residents
to explain to them what was happening
we'd also make an assessment of how much
it's used
what else is in the locality but at the
moment no decisions have been made and i
think that one is probably one where
you know it's still at very early stages
because the reason that's not used at
the moment is because there's no play
equipment in there
for the children to use and i i think
can't counter langfi langford will back
me up there we have
me and council langford have been quite
concerned about this for
for some time really and actually yeah i
think councillor langford would like to
say something but i i think
councillor langford has had a long
conversation with hayley austin
on it but councillor yes
yes come in please go to langford is
that all right thank you very much
thank you thank you tony um and thank
you barbara so far
um yeah i've had some emails with with
haley
um and then the last one um
i received from her was in october
um and she said that at the moment
obviously their emphasis was on the
the play areas in high view and stupid
road um
and at the moment they had no further
plans the reinstatements of the browns
green
site uh because of commitments in his
ongoing works but said it would be
revisited
um at the end of the financial year when
the road works
completed so that doesn't sound as if
it's necessarily in tablets of stone but
obviously
um as tony said when i saw the bowden
green 16
there i thought immediately does that
mean they're going on that site
i mean as tony said there is no there is
no play equipment there
i know there's been some sort of survey
by westwood
um of um uh 19
face-to-face surveys i believe took
place in 2019
um to try and um gauge a local feeling
about it
but i i am really concerned that there
is other building
on clavelli road uh on that area
including pridden place across the road
and if we take away these green spaces
particularly coming out of covid
um whether they're maintained as parks
play areas
just lovely green spaces that people can
go to i just think people's quality of
life is is
is affected and it does really worry me
that that was a
a re it's a really good space and and it
could be
a fantastic play area and and if it's
built on
that that worries me thank you
thank you eddie come back uh barbara
no other than you know it's early stages
we will do further consultation
i hear what you're saying and but there
is always that challenge between
you know space and providing much needed
homes
and we will have to see where that one
gets to but there are no firm decisions
yet
and haley's right we need to um finish
up in place before we can move on to
bowdoin's green
see what those existing residents say
and and what the outcome of the
consultation is
thank you uh councillor hawkins
hi thank you very much um i'd just like
to really thank you
we i had a problem with a resident on
our street
stookie road and uh you guys were really
helpful
in in sorting out the problems so thank
you for that um
just and unfortunately i missed the very
beginning of the meeting it's like
technical problem with too many
different links
so um i have that as well
i'm here now um
obviously the homeless uh the the need
for homes
is out there and it's only yesterday i
got called and i
this may not be exactly the right time
to ask this
um but i could do with some help
in finding somebody a place to move into
um
is there any particular person that i
can contact can i leave you
my details here and you can have
somebody ring me
i i can certainly have someone we knew
councillor hawkins
um but but you know it's um i mean
it is about need and i'm not saying that
we won't but you know we have a process
through devon choice-based homes
and there are priority lists and you
know we we have to stitch that process
because obviously
we want to be fair to everybody but if
it's a thing
you know quite often people don't
understand how they can go on to devon
home choice base and we can certainly
help with all of that
so um i'll um well i'm sure i can get
your um email address etc
you can get mine off of um off of mary
and just tell me who it is and we'll get
someone to ring them all in here
that's absolutely fine i think sometimes
it's uh
for my benefit as well i need to learn a
lot more about how this works
when so so i'm better prepared when
somebody asks me what their options are
absolutely
and and i haven't sent it to you but um
devon holmes
choice mike might tell you about there
is on devon county council's website and
i'll send it to mary so you can all have
it
there's advice and guidance on how you
as counsellors
can help your constituents uh find
find a an affordable home on that system
so that might be really helpful
thank you barbara uh thank you sir
oh councilor langford
sorry to chip in again now chad i don't
know if you want to do
lots of questions now we'll leave it
till the end barbara but um
can i just ask something and i apologize
for my ignorance on this but i would
just like it spelt out to me
exactly what is the difference between
social
and affordable rents how do you define
the difference
so so um thank the government of 2012
they brought in affordable rent so what
happened in 2012
was they stopped social rents which
social rents are
significantly below market then yes
and the only way that we could
get grant was by having what they called
an affordable grant
an affordable rent so an affordable rent
we are able to charge 80 percent of
market rent
and if you're charging a social event at
50 percent
that that sort of um 30
above the 50 goes into our financial
models
to help um the finances stack up so to
speak
i don't know whether that makes it i
hope that makes sense so what that means
for a customer
is there are affordability issues if you
get a social rent
that is the lowest rent possible that we
can we can we can
charge an affordable rent is much closer
to a market rent and although that helps
some people
it won't help it may not necessarily
help those people most in need
because what they will want is a social
rent
but since 2012 up until
um we had um theresa may as prime
minister
we when we did not have the ability to
build social
rented homes so you saw everybody
building either affordable or
it's the same thing intermediate rented
homes
theresa may became prime minister and
she agreed or she got government to
agree
that we could they would give grant for
social rent
because when you build a social rent
home you need something
around about 70 000 pounds worth of
grant in that home
for an affordable rent um rented home
because you're
you're basically paying for that home
partly out of the rent
you only need about 40 k's worth of
grant
so it was a way of um making us sweat
our assets and our finances more
but also it has reduced the number of
social housing properties
across the country and now we can do a
mixture
um so on many of our school schemes now
we'll have
social affordable and um
shared ownership that was very long i
hope that was um
that was clear councillor langford no
thank you
thank you that was yes i think i
understood thank you very much
okay right i think i think i've finished
on development so um
if we um go to the carbon agenda
um and this is the final area that i'll
talk about
and i'm going to talk a bit about our
green past what we've done
and our current position so if we go on
to the next slide
so so again back in 2012
um we did a great deal of work um under
the government's agenda which was the
green agenda and some of you may
remember that
a lot of that agenda was just around um
simply
educating people and assisting them with
affordable warmth
and avoiding fuel poverty there was also
grant available for new green technology
which was friendlier to the environment
and
much more efficient and i would say
supposedly
um westwood at the time took full
advantage of these grants
and we did have lots of successes but
there were also
some issues so just to remind you of
what we did
we just go to the next slide
so um what we did up in torridge was
um all homes were insulated so 100 of
our homes have lost
lost insulation we installed
solar panels in 353 of our homes
as well as cavity wall insulation in 356
of our homes
we also installed a number of new
heating
systems um but we have to say
some of those saw more challenges than
we anticipated
and especially those homes where we um
installed biomass
where our customers have experienced a
higher number
of breakdowns in those properties we've
worked with our customers
and our suppliers they work on a pellet
system
and in some cases we've actually had to
replace those systems
that's not cheap and a system will cost
us twelve thousand pound
but also because this was done under the
green agenda
we are in lease arrangements so we have
to get out of legal arrangements as well
which is not always easy
although i totally accept that the
customer is not interested in that
um fortunately apart from biomass our
air source heat pumps etc
they have been much more reliable and
are much more environmentally and
friendly
and from our parts certainly you know in
our new strategic plan we talk about
being fast followers
i don't think we would ever want to be
at the front of the queue again
because you always get these sorts of
niggles which are not great
so that's what we did under the green
agenda and
one of the things we have looked at more
recently because we've got a commitment
in our in our strategic plan is we want
all of our homes
to have an average energy performance
certificate of c
by 2025 and that's really the start of
our journey
and in towards 754 of our homes
already reached that level but we've all
but we also recognize god bless
that we've also got a way to go on that
particular
priority so if we just go to my next
slide
is your target to get to epc grade a
in a few years time is that is it no
no i mean by 2025 we will
have an average epc of c and then
by by 2050 we have to be carbon zero
but but we're doing it like that because
we do you know have to accept we have
some very old properties
but their epc is very low and we'll have
to make some hard decisions about them
but but it's you know our new properties
tend to be
either high b or low a but our older
properties
all the issues are and we can't do them
all at once i mean
um i'll repeat this in a minute but um
to do all of the work we need to do
to our our properties is going to cost
us 91 million pound
um is you know it's a huge investment um
which we have to do we all accept that
but um we have to do it in stages
it is by making hard decisions on the
older properties
does that mean knocking them down and
rebuilding
from your own level again i i don't
think um
i mean some of our properties we may
dispose of but you know
um as i pointed out to my own board when
they said well we could give all of our
our properties with very low epcs um we
could sell them off
no other social housing provider would
want them because they'd
just be inheriting more more problems
for themselves
and all you would be doing is adding to
a problem if you put them into the
private
rented market so um i think there will
be very few that we sell
where where we can we will try and adapt
them but
inevitably there will be a few but we're
i'm really thinking of some of our very
old
support schemes which are um very big
houses with lots of rooms in them they
would just and some of them have got
you know all sorts of issues and so it
would be best to
to maybe dispose of them but on the
whole we will um
retrofit our schemes thank you
okay okay so we're working with a
consultant called incredible
to establish our current carbon
footprint and then that will give us a
benchmark
to measure ourselves against each um
against each year as we move towards
carbon zero
um as i've said it's going to cost us 91
million pound we've
we've already worked that out over the
30-year period
and the biggest part of this program is
about our existing homes
but it is also about our offices and how
we work so you know we are beginning to
work
well we've all had to work haven't we in
an agile
way and you know we're on this meeting
today and i all know that we want
face-to-face contact but you know by not
driving to
um the council offices we're all saving
the um
the environment to a certain degree um
so our plan is being worked on now and
once we have our plan
we'll begin to communicate that with our
colleagues customers and stakeholders
but at the moment it's at a very early
stage
but we will obviously if you'd like us
to come back and talk to you about that
more so i'm now on my last slide you'll
be pleased to know
um and that just leaves me to say um
i've come to the end of my presentation
thank you for listening and if you've
got any further questions i'm very happy
to attempt to answer them we'll come
back to you later
great i look forward to a question then
concussion langford please
sorry me again
um i've just got two things barbara and
thank you so much for this
and comprehensively answering our
questions that we sent in
um one thing i must just say that i was
so delighted to hear that
you reassured people they wouldn't lose
their home at the start of the coveted
crisis etc
but um just two things the first thing
um is um we've we specifically asked
about
properties for um single people or
one and two bedroom properties but i've
been thinking about it on the other end
of the scale
looking at the information you sent i
think there's only one property in the
torridge area for a fam
for um five um
now i wondered is there any is there any
possibility of having or what are your
thoughts about larger properties because
obviously for large families
um they might be forced into the private
sector
um if um they can't find anything
provided by yourselves do you see what
i'm saying i i do
if if we have the ability to find
somewhere where we could build a social
event that would
that would be great and and it's really
a conversation
that our team would be having with your
enabling team
because it's about the need you know if
you've got a real need for that then
clearly we would
we would try to meet you and build that
what we found with larger properties
once they start
to get over sort of like four bed five
beds
if they are built in as an affordable
rent
and people can't afford them and i know
that sounds horrendous
and we're left in the situation that
you're actually putting somebody
into a home that you know that they're
not going to be able to afford in the
long term
and then we get into issues around um
you know careers etc
so if we can get the quran if that there
is a definite need for there there is no
reason why we couldn't build
those types of homes for those families
but you know
it's about looking at the need within
the the area and what is actually
required which is part of
our um is part of our process
when we look at building a new scheme
okay thank you um i mean that came about
a specific query from somebody
um with a large family and also a
disabled member of the family so
it was very specific but uh or by the
way david brenton said to me could i
please say hello to you for him
yeah he's been on yeah yeah yeah david
the other thing uh very quickly and this
is nitpicking i just thought i'd mention
it as you're here
um in the play areas information that
you sent through which was great it
mentioned at the
high view um the swings would be
replaced
um in february i just want to let you
know that they haven't happened
yeah and um there's some temporary
fencing around the area for the little
ones there doesn't seem to be any fire
damage there i've had a look i can't see
what the fire damage is but there's
still some temporary fencing there
and the swings aren't in place so i'm
just mentioning
it as you're here thank you no no that
that is fine and i will i'll get an
update i would imagine it's just we have
got backlog with repairs and whether
people
get out there so i'll i'll get haley to
she's on holiday this week but i'll get
her to have a look at that
okay thank you very much good job
leather
thank you chair thank you to barbara
shaw for the presentation
it was very very informative and to the
point and thank you for sending out the
briefing paper beforehand
that was very useful i would like to add
my weight to
tony incheon and to shirley on the
bowdoin green one that for a long time
has concerned me that
it's been let go as it has because it
used to be a very good play area though
and i do take your point about
the choice between building new homes
but play areas play spaces green spaces
are so important on new developments and
existing developments
i would i wouldn't like to see that go
my question is
when a tenant dies and of course
unfortunately we know a lot do and you
do have quite a lot of elderly
tenants how far any family members that
reside there
automatic right to that tenancy
it depends it depends what their tenancy
is
and how long they've lived there so you
do have to i mean i've not done housing
management for a while but
um i think you have to live there for at
least
a year it may be longer but it does
depend on the nature
of your tendency it has to be a
particular type of tendency
and and we have had cases where it's
been very sad where um
we've not been able to just give
somebody a tenancy
um but there have been cases where we
have been able to
and but it's not an automatic right it
very much depends people need to look at
their tenancy
or ask their housing officer so there's
a bit of insecurity there for some
family members who might live with a
an elderly mother or father isn't it
really yeah
and maybe they've lived there all the
life you know if they've lived there all
their life
again if they have an assured tendency
it may well be that they can but i am
just saying
it depends on the tenancy and it depends
on how long you've lived there if you've
lived there all your life then obviously
that that will
be in your favor but it does depend on
the tenancy
um i would imagine that i would imagine
the majority
of tenants uh tenancies in college do
have that right
but i wouldn't want to swear to it at
this stage without having looked at them
all counselling
thank you thank you for that thank you
guys another counselor
newton
uh barbara good afternoon thank you very
much for a very interesting presentation
my name is simon newton i'm the
counselor out at
winkley um just um
prompted by personal experience earlier
this year
um could i implore that um
two things first of all you were
stressing your emphasis on customer
engagement
um the pickup time
on your customer hub number the standard
casual number
100 110 10 it can
be ages and ages i
had to call probably
about eight or ten times earlier this
year
trying to sort out uh one of my
residents um
issues and every time you
get onto it you are sat waiting
listening to music for i mean i meant
literally i must have spent
hours waiting over course of 10 10 calls
um over two week period and
i would suggest that your a long
long time waiting on a phone
sends a message to you and it sends a
message
saying actually we we're not loaded
front end with the capacity
to to deal with answering questions
that's the impression that it gives
the reality may be different i know but
uh i would implore you to look at that
i think your pickup reaction time is
slow
and and therefore automatically
um causes anguish
on the the resident who's probably
phoning with a
with a with a problem that that's got
them quite wound up anyhow
um and their their level of tolerance
may be fairly
maybe coming from a fairly low base in
the first place um
and their when they then had to wait for
15 minutes before a humanoid will
actually answer the phone
um the they are steaming by that point
their language selection then is
probably pretty ropey
and you then get met by um very strong
um uh language not language but um
uh quotes from the other end uh
telling people that you will ring off if
they don't calm down and everything else
well
to a lot of my residents
who live in social housing um
i'm afraid that will very quickly just
winds the whole thing up even more
uh and the purpose is to obviously uh
sort the problem out um so i just
i would just pick up on that but there
is it can
take a long time to get through to you
on that number
so could i just ask one one thing for
clarification
and when you said earlier this year do
you mean this year or last year no this
this year uh i was it was
um in fact it was the end of last year i
think it was december
um december uh 2020.
um but um anyway i just make that point
no no no and thank you for making that
point because we have made
we have made lots of effort and the
stats that i see
are saying to me that on average
um we answer the calls within
three minutes clearly that was not your
experience so we need to have a look at
that
but we have also experienced some
problems with our um
telephone system which we're replacing
this year but um it is unacceptable if
you had a surly member of staff so i
will feed that back to the
hub council i'm i'm i'm easy and i've
got
broad shoulders and fairly tough skin
and and
that i'm not the problem isn't affecting
me
uh however i and i i'm i come from a
background of 36 years of soldier
um where i've been dealing with soldiers
in in
in army married quarters all over the
country
and all the issues of servicing those
i know how um very quickly
um these things can get very steamed up
um
my other question would be you pointed
out
um that the biomat the insulation of
biomass heating systems has not been a
great success
um i also in winkley have had
issues with residents with a
repeated breakdown with biomass i was
alarmed to find out
that the the
call out expectation on a biomass
breakdown
because apparently it's technically
difficult is six days
um and in at the end of last year we had
sub-zero
um temperatures and i had a resident who
had to wait
six working days for somebody to come
and fix their
boiler oh we don't we don't leave them
without heat we
offer them normally other source of
heating somebody called by
and and offered yes a couple of electric
radiators or whatever
um whereas the the people that you call
out to fix
it are up the road in torrington and
when the engineer
comes to the house he said well
he said we've been on call 24 7. he said
a phone call we could have come
instantly but it's all
through contracts etc you have a system
which you accept
is defective and you've had lots of
problems and yet actually
it doesn't look like the the
reaction to it has been
increased as a result um
i leave that as it is in my background
leaving somebody in uh a house
as a tenant or let's put it diff in in
reverse
in my house and i'm fortunate i i live
in my own house which i own
if my boiler breaks down i don't wait
six days for it to be fixed
or if the technician can't get to me
within six days he doesn't see the light
of my door again
um it it must be a a
slow contract or
it must be bureaucratic i understand
there's a middle middle agency that
people have to go through
um in order to react and i just in a
general term
i i just wonder how um sharp
your um your call out systems are in
that area
um i will have a look at that all i can
say is i feel we've done a lot of work
there
there are you know we do offer
alternative heating you may feel that's
not
acceptable um we will look at the
contract but you know
that that if that is the contract then
we obviously need to review it but
um i haven't got that detail at my
fingertips i don't know whether that
came in as a complaint
whether that person received
compensation i i have no
idea um but we can certainly look into
that
um but you know i accept biomass has not
been brilliant
um it is not our finest hour but
actually
um to replace all of those biomass
systems
would cost us a significant amount of
money
and we have other priorities it's it's
it's that whole thing about we should
never have gone first
that is an excuse for the customer
though but we'll certainly have a look
at what our contract says um because i'm
not aware that it says six days
do not leave people without heating it's
certainly the the way you're admitting
that your system is
is not um great in biomass
uh i i would strongly encourage you to
to look at um letting a sharper contract
on on servicing it because you obviously
get
more problems with it um and i will see
what we've done but we have changed our
contract to
several times but there there aren't a
huge amount of contractors on biomass
but we will certainly have a look at it
counseling thanks very much sorry to
label the point
no no that's okay
right i see no further hands because i
have yes councillor carl hunken
hello um i was just wondering there
doesn't appear to be any plans for new
homes in great torrington
on your list and i was wondering whether
that was considered in the 2020 strategy
so in terms of where we decide to skip
to to develop it depends on a lot of
things it depends on
is there land available is anybody
selling land
is there a is there a big developer
who's building a scheme
where we will have an opportunity for
106. so
it's not about us choosing where we want
to
actually build it's what are the
opportunities that arise
that we can build upon um and
you know that is about do you know land
owners what are your connections etc
it doesn't you can't just go out there
and say i want to build
i'd like to build you know i don't know
next to exeter cathedral
it just doesn't work like that it's all
about what are the opportunities that
are available
and then it's about if you're buying a
piece of land how competitive you are in
the marketplace
and if it's a 106 it depends on you know
have you got a relationship with that
particular developer
or has the local authority got a say on
who is going to deliver that 106. so
it is it is difficult to find sites
and find them sometimes in the areas
where people feel it's most pressing
they're okay um i don't know whether
that helps
yeah yeah you're happy with the answers
cheryl
yeah thank you okay i've got a couple of
hands in there casual leather first
and then counselor tony and it's the
leather thank you chair
yeah my next question really is on
something when we were looking at
questions
for this uh overview and scrutiny item
was resident representation on the board
or
at westwood i do remember when the
council house in stock in
torridge was given away and it became
tonka housing
there was um tenants tenants actually
had representation
directly on that board then i know it's
changed over time
but the question that we did asked was
what resident representation which
should really be
tenant representation do you have and
i'll notice that you had campbell tickle
do
a survey and they only looked at five
percent of five percent of residents
which isn't a very high number about 90
what 94 out of the 18
nearly 1900 in torridge and they spoke
with residents staff and board members
and then
from this they produced a draft customer
engagement strategy
and then it goes on for just say that
the strategy has been further considered
cons consulted on and approved by the
board this month
and you've appointed a customer insight
manager
lead an action in the strategy plan that
we haven't got any clue
what that strategy plan isn't it really
doesn't answer
what kind of input tenants will have
with with
westwood well i think i think the five
percent is
that is a formula that people use to say
that they have got a representative
response whether you agree with that or
not is
is your view our current representation
we don't do representation on our board
it's about skills and experience that
was a discussion
that happened when we combined all of
our
boards together what we do have is a
customer senate at the moment
and the chair of the customer senate
comes to the board
and the senate mostly gets to comment on
all of our board papers
i think you'll also see in the q a that
we've shown you that
with the customer engagement strategy
which we have
produced over the summer with our
customers and not just customers in
towards but across westwood
there is a recommendation that our
customer panel
becomes much more of a scrutiny panel
which although the
the customer cent does have a scrutiny
role it's not their only role
so we're going to go out and recruit on
that we've done lots of
um further engagement with our customers
and to see what they would like
and and they have said that they feel
that that is appropriate
um you'll also see on your q a that
we've done
other consultations we've done a lot of
work on services in terms of customer
mapping
and the three services that we've looked
at today is relex
antisocial behavior and repairs because
those are the three issues
that people tend to and talk to us about
most
and that is about what would be better
what would be slicker
for you in terms of that process and
procedure
we've done consultation at morwenna so i
think
in my experience people
aren't as obsessed about being part of
the board
what they want is involvement in what's
going to happen
on their particular scheme or estate
so again that's what we're focusing a
lot of our time
on very happy to send you the strategy
which also has an action plan
the standards will be consulted on
during the summer
and they will be the standards which our
customers can expect
when they make contacts
but we don't have representation on our
board
it's not like a council and certainly
with our regulator
their view of governance is about skills
and experience that's not to say
that a resident couldn't be on a board
but there wouldn't be a
seat specially made yeah
well i reckon a lot of tenants have got
skills and experience it would be
worthwhile i mean but that's a separate
thing
what could you just expand a little bit
on this customer senate then
exactly what is or who is that what is
that
the customer senate is made up of a
number of our customers across the
organization
their role is to scrutinize to look at
performance
and to commission other activity
um to improve our services they meet on
a quarterly basis or did do
up until covid they would receive
reports and presentations from
officers and then as i i say those
the outcomes of their their opinions or
those meetings would then be taken to
the board
okay thank you pleasure thank you uh
because another
tony inc scheduler tony inch thank you
chairman
um yeah i was going to ask the same sort
of thing as as
um chris leather there that's been
answered but
the other the other thing as well is
that um
i know you've you meet did you say you
meet every month for every
so often with the chief executive steve
every six months every six every six
months well
i think perhaps in the view of this
pandemic
and when we come out of this pandemic
things are going to change a bit i think
in the public
sector on the rents we've already seen
now
on the social media of people putting up
um requests that um you know they're
looking for houses
their tech their their landlord is
giving them notice
i know that the government said they
can't give a notice
uh for six months but they argue on that
six months notice now
and uh because landlords are
wanting to sell uh housing
uh um value has gone up a bit
landlords are feeling the pinch like
anybody else
and they're wishing to sell and um
i'm just concerned that the private
rental is going to drop off a cliff
at the end of this pandemic or fairly
you know towards the end or fairly soon
after the end
and torridge and westwood housing are
going to be
um inundated with people wanting to rent
and the housing is not going to be there
and um
i just feel that perhaps you ought to be
meeting with our chief executive
a little bit um more than six months
um you know i think the pandemic will
have a
great effect on the housing and i think
that uh perhaps you should be meeting
him
at least every two months now um
it's just a suggestion but i think it
may be
maybe a good idea thank you
um thank you i will um i will make that
suggestion to him when i meet with him
i think it's at the end of this month
thank you
yeah coaster hawkins
i know i i'm saying this i think i think
you're absolutely right tony yeah
um you you've got a really good point
there i think things are going to get
uh far worse um quite quickly
um i've often wondered with some of the
external organizations that we um this
is uh
bringing back a point that uh simon uh
councillor newton
raised uh i too had quite a long wait
when it came to uh making some phone
calls and i just sort of feel that
sometimes
the types of questions that uh uh we as
councillors will be asking
are sort of that they're different to
to maybe what the resident is trying to
get information about
it's almost like i feel like the council
need
sort of a hotline into uh some of these
larger organizations um not that we're
special
by any means but um
one of the counsellor could probably end
up needing to phone up three or four
times in a month or a week
for different residents and have the
issues of waiting quite a long time for
the course
uh have you ever considered um
not a separate line no um but certainly
um you
you now have the director's emails and
the best way to
contact them is via an email and then if
you want them to phone you then
ask them to phone you but that is the
best way we don't
you know we we you know it's like all
organizations
we need to streamline we need to be
efficient
and that's the way that we now operate
through that line
but you know the best way to contact i
would suggest our directors
is through that that email that you've
been given
thank you very much
okay barbara just a couple of questions
from me
to follow along reflects very much what
um tony was saying um
coach durant was saying a little a
minute or two ago about the
private rental sector and and all the
pressure you're on
um how many evictions did you carry out
a year before the pandemic
we prior to the pandemic we only we
carried out four
and that was across the organization
we're not in the you know if we evict
somebody that is a failure
and we are not in we are not in this job
to evict people we're you know we're not
you know we would much rather make an
arrangement with somebody
clearly i would have to say this year we
have had
two residents that we have taken to core
but that is because they were in arrears
before we went into the pandemic
and they have failed to communicate with
us
so you know we are wanting to talk to
them about how we can help them
etc but that really is um a last resort
i mean we do not we are not in the
business of the victim people that is
not what we want
but we need to have an arrangement with
people you know they need to talk to us
i just wondered because you know you
were very
i was that cheered me to hear you say
that no tenant would be evicted due
to from coronavirus which i think was
the worst
earlier speaking um but do you envision
that
for to rise given the pandemic we've
been through
secondly it's not quite linked but it is
in a way because when you go to the
private sector
the rents are generally higher than what
they are in the
uh social sector um and
where people have lost their jobs
they've been generally in pretty high
paid jobs
housing you're in a situation that um
reviews have grown up very quickly and
you're going to have a huge wave coming
forward
so yeah be very interesting to see how
that matches as tony has said
but you don't see a great rise in
evictions even at the end of the corona
virus which i
i am really cheered about i have to say
and i really want to thank you for that
work the way you've done that
thank you thank you and you know it is
about having arrangements in place
and that's what what we really want to
do you know
as long as people are paying a bit of
their areas off and a bit of their rent
that's what's important
and let's hope that they can all you
know those people who've lost jobs do
get jobs at the end of this when
we can get back out there and start the
economy going again
right the second point i wanted to raise
um i'm interested in wood pellets
now i'm i'm sitting in front of a 1961
raven here and i got all the wood behind
me if you can see
that we put into the river and it's
given me now 60
years of good service it's fantastic
this heaps all our water and everything
else
um but i haven't got any claim left back
on the company because it did break down
last week for the first time
and i did ask if they would do anything
under warranty and they said no
now i just wonder if you've got any
claim on warranty against that would
i've heard a lot of people say a lot of
difficulty about the wood pellet stuff
and is there any misselling or any claim
you could have back to speed up the
process for people facing cold times
next winter next i don't think we're
going to get as cold again this winter
as we've had
actually i mean we have no claim the
company that actually put them all
in has now disappeared and so that does
not help
where where we've had the biggest issues
we have tried to replace those
um those systems
and we have really worked hard with
those customers to try and improve the
quality of the pellets
there's a whole issue around the dust
that the pellets create and how that
clogs up the system i mean they are just
very delicate systems
and i think eventually you know we may
well have to have
you know a period when we start to
replace them all
but at the moment that's just not viable
but you know some people although we
you know we quite likely focused on
those people who have the issues
there are some people who have those
systems and and and they work for them
um they may well have just been lucky i
don't know
um you know it's the same with a car
isn't it um but it's
you know i accept that it's not great um
we work with our customers we make sure
that if they break down they get some
sort of alternative heating
um and you know we we provide them with
compensation
but you know i do understand that it's
frustrating for some of them but we're
working hard to try and improve that
but it you know it's just a very
difficult situation and we've all been
there
um but we are doing our best to resolve
it
well thank you very much for your your
presentations for sending the
information forward for the way you've
spoken and answering questions at the
present moment
um what i'd like to do with the
agreement the committee is ask helen
smith to come forward as a torah
district council officer
now who do devon home choice um
for you can i just ask one brief
question certainly
i didn't see your hand no i i'm having
difficulty mate hey not the first time
won't be the last
person or apple door representative
thank you chair yeah i'll keep this
brief to the point because it's touched
on before about
the social uh rent and the affordable
rent
now obviously it's 50 and 80 but fifty
and eight percent of what then
is that based on what is the actual base
figure that you get the percentage from
is that from
private sector rent is it great courage
um right if you i'll i'll be quiet a
minute and i might come back
so if you could answer that so i think i
i
couldn't quite hear you but the 80 of
market rent
is whatever the average market rent
would be
in the district of torridge yeah so it's
not
for instance if you've got a property in
apple to wear a social rental affordable
way
that's not based necessarily on the
rental that you would get in appledore
that is actually
average day through a weighted mean or
whatever for eight hours correct
hello is that correct yes right right so
what i'm getting at you ain't going to
say this but i'm going to say it for
for you or actually more so from
yourself so if you
if you basically start off with an
excessive high rent
based on profiteering and then you end
up with a higher 50 percent because if
you go up for instance
two no i'll say it if you've got no i'll
say it for you i didn't make the rules
up the government
no but let's be brutally honest that's
where we that's where we're at aren't we
because if we were talking historically
say
for instance say 30 or 40 years ago
probably
probably is only probably there's less
greed around
that is my perception i would say a
perception of a lot of people to be
brutally honest
and just picking up another point which
you're absolutely right on
but again you can't partner and we'll
expect you you've done a great
presentation by the way really
appreciate that
um but wouldn't it be great perhaps if
we could go back to 90s up to 1961
whereby you didn't have the one of uh
one or six agreements or whatever you
already
automatically add a share of selling
people
selling land and um let's be brutally
honest in the last 30 or 40 years a lot
of landowners that was agriculturally
owned this made a bloody killing i will
save me the bloody killing i don't mind
about the public hearing that by the way
that's right yes
just please mind too much of that uh
yeah yeah it won't go any stronger than
that um but obviously it's expected you
can say word again
no no and i won't see something you're
in a nice chapter we've got a lovely
smile there today cherry you're right i
promise i'll be a
but basically what i'm getting at on
this point
and let's be brutally honest and this is
not about politics at all it's
irrelevant
but wouldn't it be great perhaps if
sometimes we could actually go back to
the good old times where you can
actually have completely purchase
at the right cost for the right things
in the right area and with that chair
i'll behave yourself and go quiet thank
you
thank you for your understanding uh
barbara do you want to make a comment or
respond to that
no i i agree i mean um i i was brought
up on a council estate that was built
because my mum and dad lived in london
and couldn't afford to buy a home there
but my dad got a job in what is called
swindon
and with that he got a council home and
it was absolute bliss but those days
have gone and it is a great shame but we
we are where we are yeah and we have to
do the best we can with what we've got
um and it's not ideal um and my only not
that i'm here to make political
statements but
we all need to accept that not everybody
can own their own home
and what is desperately required is
social housing
but i don't make up the rules i'm i'm
just trying to deliver what we've done
um with what we've got linking into
a very perfect question from chris
before then um can i just follow on from
that one
because i think it was ten days ago
there was um
a new scheme introduced by central
government
where by a five percent deposit would
secure
i i think it was a shared ownership of
right now no no no
that was five you could have a 95
mortgage with a five percent deposit
okay that goes back to the days when
people used to get a
unbelievably 125 percent mortgage if
they paid an assurance but they still
became liable when it all went
pear-shaped exactly
and all that all that could do is push
people into debt
if interest rates go up so can i
is it a political comment i don't know
if it's fair to ask but what do you
how do you view this new return to a low
deposit because
the low deposit is what has barred
youngsters having
you know having the wherewithal to buy
property
and on a let's say a 200 000 pound house
with a
certain rise we've had across torrance
that's twelve thousand pound a year
increase on that property um they
haven't got
what is 50 000 pounds in the bank to
give a 25
deposit um um so i just wanted
if you you've got any fears in this
direction or how you saw that affecting
the market in where we are today
well i i think all it will do for the
market is increase
the value of property because there'll
be more people out there looking for
homes which
obviously you'll be bidding on on a
property
but i think it will push people into
debt um
which won't be great and we'll go back
to that negative equity
issue but i think you know what we need
to see and people won't like this
is we need to see a drop in housing um
in in the housing market in terms of the
cost of property
right because we're all driving up the
cost of property
um i can't you know i bought my house a
long long time ago
and it cost fifty thousand pound people
would say that's a bargain now
my parents eventually bought their house
for seven thousand pounds
you know but but it's the cost of a
house
is the biggest expense anybody will ever
have
but it's also out of the reach of so
many people i think the
average first time buyer now is um
39 40 years old because it takes so long
unless you've got a really rich mum and
dad
to to get a deposit well very
very thorough answers again thank you
very much for that
right i see no other hands going up at
the present moment
um what i would like to do is ask helen
smith to come forward and
yeah helen it's helen page helen smith's
the planning officer
helen i do apologize i did see your
picture come up briefly just now
so it's helen pagey with the committee's
agreement um you know
if helen um would like to put her um
explain to us how devon home choice
works um and then we've got any
questions any recommendations we would
like to
make good to our two speakers this
afternoon can i ask helena
paige yes i'm quite happy for helen
smith to take over if she wants
well there you are uh i'm very happy for
you
i do apologize uh so so if you can lead
us and then
and on devon home choice please so i've
been asked to give a
a brief overview of devon home choice
and it is quite a brief overview
so i would encourage people to have a
look
at the devon home choice website for
further information
because there are some really useful
guides videos
policy and procedure documents on there
including a member's guide
which will have answers to frequently
asked questions
so that would be useful for people to
look at the devon home choice was formed
in 2010
and it's made up of a partnership of
local authorities
and housing associations so that would
include
plymouth torbay and all the district
local authorities
and all the housing associations with
stock within devon
most social housing properties in devon
are allocated through devon home choice
and it's a choice-based letting scheme
so what that means it aims to give
people choice about the properties that
they want to be considered for
and it also gives them the ability to
move around within devon if they wish
what i would point out it's not a list
or register where applicants can can
register the application and then sit
back and wait for an offer to be made
to them applicants need to be proactive
in searching for properties and placing
bids
although if an applicant isn't able to
do that that we have got the ability to
set up auto bids for them
if you'd like to move on to next slide
please
so registering on devon home choice
people
are encouraged to register online
through the website
but again if an applicant is unable to
do that there are paper application
forms available to them
if an applicant lives in torridge their
application is administered
by housing options at torrance district
council
and if an applicant lives outside of
devon but they would like to
move to torridge their application will
also be administered by housing options
at torridge
when an african registers their details
they'll need to answer several questions
about their household their
circumstances
their finances their health requirements
and where they've lived in the past
assistance with making an application is
available
and that is available through housing
options um
and to access that help people can
telephone the switchboard number
and ask to be put through to devon home
choice or they can email
a specific email addresses listed there
can you move to the next slide please
so how applicants are assessed so
once the application is received and all
the relevant
information is there an application will
be assessed
within 20 working days and the applicant
will receive
written confirmation of how their
application is banded
what band start date they've been given
and the size of home that they can bid
for
and whether they're limited to certain
types of property
it's important that applicants tell the
council about any changes in their
circumstances
after they've registered their
application because that may mean that
their application needs to be reassessed
again applicants can make changes to
their application online
or they can contact housing options by
telephone or email
for assistance can you move to the next
slide please
so the crucial part when someone
registers on devon home choice
is their banding and the banding is
how applications are prioritized
and the applications are prioritized
according to
housing need with band a being the
highest banding
and band e being the lowest banding
um and so band a is the emergency
housing need
and very few applicants will ever be
placed
in band aid and i've got some stats to
show this
later on band b is generally the highest
band that an applicant can
expect to be awarded um and that is
where it's recognized that
there is a very high housing need
i won't read through all the categories
in terms of the assessment it
can be quite complicated
so i'm not going to read through the
whole list but just to give you an idea
severe overcrowding where someone lacks
two bedrooms
might lead to band b being awarded
lacking one bedroom would be band c um
and band d would be where someone has no
permanent home or
sharing facilities um with people who
are not
part of their household would you like
to move to the next slide please
so just to explain in case there were
ever any queries over this
it can the situation can arise where
someone may
expect to be awarded a high or medium
band such as bambi or band c
but actually end up being placed in a
lower band
and that could be because they've got
the financial means to resolve their own
housing and therefore they'd be placed
in band e
or they've deliberately worsened their
circumstances and an example of this
might be where
an applicant say may be awarded ban b
for severe overcrowding because they
lack two bedrooms
but actually when we look into their
circumstances
they may have deliberately moved into a
property where they would be
overcrowded to that extent so they would
begin to deliberately worsen their
circumstances and may well be placed in
band
d for a period of time of at least 12
months
if an applicant applies and they owe
rent arrears of over 500 pounds to a
landlord they may well also be placed in
band e
rather than a higher banding according
to their housing need
and applicants who apply to devon home
choice who have got
no local connection are will be placed
in band
d even if they have got a recognized
housing need
can you move to the next slide please so
sorry this has come up quite small but
to try and give you an idea
of households registered on devon home
choice
um there's a list there and also the
other authority areas so
we can compare um but generally as of uh
january there were 1100
households registered on devon home
choice in torridge
um and just breaking it down by band
there you can see
um that very few applicants will ever be
awarded
band a because band a is generally
awarded
where the need is so high that it
perhaps would be a matter of life and
death
and that the applicant needs to be
awarded priority over most
other applicants
should i just pause there to see if
there's any questions regarding
these statistics because it's generally
the statistics that people are
interested in
right i think um just before the i asked
the committee to come back on that one i
just want to
i think we've lost barbara and i she had
a 3 30 meeting
um i just wanted to record our thanks to
barbara for being with us afternoon
before some questions to her
later on and we'll go back and now go to
the counselors here
um to pick up uh any questions you have
on on this uh
um these statistics here across the
districts of devon
i i'm
just moving my cursor here to have a
look at the numbers
torridge taurus charge charge okay
right i see no hands going up you've
mesmerized us with numbers helen
okay okay no questions on those numbers
that take a little bit of digesting
actually
and and again the next slide shows the
bedroom need
of applicants register on devon home
choice
and uh the most significant thing to
point out here
is that obviously there is a a high need
for one bedroom properties
what is that graph showing helen sorry i
can't see the top what
what the actual graph is numbering
that's okay
so it shows the bedroom need of the
applicants registered on devon home
choice
so it shows the size property that they
require
and what that does show is that the
greatest need is for one bedroom
properties and that is not just
across storage that is reflected across
the whole county
the target's got quite a low number
along with team bridge as i as i
interpret those figures very quickly
well it's still 50 percent requiring one
bedroom property
why is exodus a high at 61 higher than
plymouth
does that include university university
no no this would be people registered on
devon home choice where it's recognized
that they've got a housing need
and and the other thing i would point
out is when you look at
the need for larger properties of need
for four bedroom plus properties
that is significantly reduced
and that does make it more challenging
for
the social landlords to develop the
larger properties because there is
generally less demand for them
so then when they look at their
financial models it is quite
challenging for them to develop the
larger properties
okay another question making them there
i see that comparing north devon
torridge
you have um 344 in torridge 819 in north
devon
is that corrupt have i interpreted that
correctly this is about need not actual
houses
yes this is about need okay
i mean um uh torridge is 65 000 people
and north dakota's 90 000 people
why is it so great in north devon it's
more than two and a half times
the number of of one bedroom properties
wanted in in
north devon compared to torch what is is
the difference there
causing that huge
not sure i can answer that i couldn't
comment on that i don't think
okay well there thank you for any other
question i don't see any hands up here
okay that's right all gone quiet guys
yeah carry on our way helen
thank you so if we move forward please
and this is just to show you how um
the numbers registered on devon home
choice have changed over a period of
time
um it is a little bit um deceiving
because back in 2018
we had some difficulties with the uh
devon home choice software where we
could not
renew people's applications
and basically what happens with devon
home choice is every year people are
asked
to tell us whether they want to remain
on devon home choice or whether they
want their application removed
and there was a significant period of
time where we weren't removing people's
applications so the numbers went up and
up and up
so the best indication would be over the
last two years about the number of
applications
and just to echo what's been said
previously we are expecting
the numbers registered on dev and home
choice to continue to increase
over the next 12 months or so
any questions yes a hand from claire
hudson
councillor hodgson thank you very much
mr chairman
um it really refers back i didn't get my
hand up quick enough
um to the previous slide and your
question regarding
the high level of demand for one bed
properties
and forgive me i got called away in the
middle of helen's
uh um introduction to
devon home choice but did you talk helen
um and i'll shush if you did about
who qualifies for one bedroom that
it would be a couple with no requirement
to have
a a second bedroom for medical reasons
or care reasons so therefore perhaps in
north devon
we've got more applications coming from
couples looking for accommodation where
there is
uh greater opportunities for employment
and i wonder if that aspect of the
demographic
um plays a role in this and it's not
one bedroom a single person it it's one
bedroom
for a a couple so
um am i correcting that i would had you
covered that helen i apologize if you
had
no i hadn't covered it you may well be
correcting that
with about sort of fitting further
detail around north devon's
statistics compared to torridges i'm not
sure if i could comment on that
confidently
no no well i suppose it's speculative on
my part but
having dealt with sort of applications
for home choice systems
um it has to be recognized you don't
just say
well we're a couple and we'd like a
spare bedroom because you wouldn't
qualify for that
when your assessment of your application
was being made
and i think i'm correcting
thank you chair well my question is
as helen said when she spoke about
people registering with devon home
choice
and then their application is then
handed over to torridge
to be administered now what does that
administration
compose com comprise of do
you investigate the needs of that person
do you investigate their current housing
where they are and
when it's administered by our housing
options team
precisely what do they do we do
so the onus is on the applicant to
provide the council with information to
support their application
so if there is a health and wellbeing
need
they would complete a supporting
evidence form
to show what their health and well-being
need they may well
have the opportunity to ask for medical
professionals
to also provide information but
generally other than sort of around
health and well-being
the information is is taken um
on on face value there are some
investigations
but the verification of someone's
circumstances
tends to take place more if they are
shortlisted for a property
so we do carry out inquiries and
investigations in order to award a
banding
but if you like all that information is
double checked
at the point that someone is shortlisted
for a property to make sure that all the
information is correct
and relevant
so when when when somebody goes on devon
home choice and fills in an application
do they state
they want two bed or one bed or three
bed and then that application
you're notified of it or are you are you
notified at the same time that they
applied to them choice
so the the bedroom need is decided by
the household size
other than that if there is a medical
reason why
why a couple may well need two bedrooms
rather than one bedroom
so that is all part of the assessment
the assessment would decide
what bedroom size property
and what banding should be awarded
and when somebody does apply if they
want two
bedrooms it might be a single person but
it might be a single person that might
need
overnight care on occasions not not
necessarily every night
but on a kitchen it might mean a member
of their family
staying with them overnight or a care
worker from one of the agencies coming
in to stay
is that taken into consideration it is
taken into consideration so if someone
simply wants a second bedroom because
they would like family to visit for
example
that wouldn't be permitted they would be
deemed to have a one bed need
but if there is a reason why a second
bedroom might be required for
a carer or for a particular need
then yes there may well be the
opportunity
for people to be considered for a
two-bedroom property for that reason
and ellen i don't know if you can answer
this next bit but council tax
um i'll you know allocation of council
tax help etc
and bet housing benefit again we've all
heard about the bedroom tax it isn't
actually a tax on bedrooms but it's
called the bedroom tax
i'm on about again would that apply with
that or not i know it's not
probably strictly it's
yeah it's difficult what we say to
people is
that housing options accepting that
someone hasn't
has got a uh a need for two bedrooms
or a need for an additional bedroom
doesn't necessarily
mean that benefits will make that same
decision
so it's two separate assessments so
whilst it might be recognized that
someone has a housing need
that doesn't mean that they will be paid
benefits for that second room
this is where more join up thinking is
needed in my view
you know because if somebody does need a
second bedroom for
for care and it might only be occasional
care once a week
might be two nights a week or whatever
then there should be some link up
between both where
they're swimming from the same sheet in
my view but thanks for your answer evan
stacy might want to contribute to this
discussion
yeah thank you chair i was just coming
back on council lover's point in fact we
had
um exact circumstance of that and very
recently
um that came through from the hardship
fund and
exact circles as soon as he he had a
two-bedroom property but needed a carrot
to stay in not all the time
um but two nights a week and and he was
awarded the benefit to
to pay the bedroom tax so again and
that's joe well
his team but if there are specific needs
like that then the assessment can be
done and if they
they do need the second one for that
reason then quite often it can be funded
up
through the benefits scheme for them so
again a lot of the time people don't
know and don't know to make the
application
applications
i suppose part of it is getting the
message out there to applicants as well
because this chat was really really
struggling um and wasn't aware that that
application could be made
thank you stacy yeah thank you thanks
for that stacy that's um
you know it's up to us to make sure
people know about that because i think
it would apply
to quite a lot of people across our
district to be honest
okay can i just follow on from chris
another's question as well because um
there's one group with people um the
worry is it's usually
uh when it's a family breakdown
relationship the the man leaves the
house
but he has a contact order sometimes
with his children
um and does that qualify for for
uh health and well-being reasons um to
have a second bedroom
i just wondered how that would fit into
your scheme of things in that sense
not normally it we judge it on who is in
receipt of the child benefit
so
yeah so let's just pretend there was a
uh
a guy there with a adolescent daughter
he has a contact order with how does he
maintain that contact with
and i i'm sorry i don't mean to be
sexist and asking
that's usually the configuration that
happens
along the way and it's maintaining that
contact that sometimes can be so
important
i just wondered so if a parent has a
visiting
child then they will not be awarded a
bedroom for that child
well that's i find that hard but thank
you for your answer
yeah okay right then i don't see any
other hands up here at the moment
um okay if we can move on to next slide
please
so just some information there on how
homes are advertised
so the homes that are available are
advertised each week
and they're advertised on the website
through a smartphone
app and applicants can also download
so that they get property alerts homes
are advertised
from 12am on a wednesday until 11 59 p.m
the following monday
and i would stress with that it's not a
first-come first-served basis
so applicants do not have need to sit up
till
the early hours of the morning thinking
that if they bid as quickly as possible
they're going to be prioritized for a
property because it does not work like
that
now within the advert it will give
details regarding the property location
it will not give an exact address
because what we don't want is sometimes
properties are advertised while there's
still a tenant in them and what we don't
want is lots of people wandering around
the garden trying to have a look at the
property
so we tend not to give the exact address
but uh but uh but a location it will
give the property size
the rent details and any particular
features of the home
the name of the landlord and any special
requirements or priority that will be
given
so some properties may have a section
106 agreement on them so
it will be a preference to a local
connection to
a particular parish or town
and the advert will also state whether
any preference will be given to
particular mobility needs
so an example of this might be where
there's a level access
shower installed in a property then
priority will be given to someone who
would benefit
both from that facility
so if we move forward to the next slide
please
so applicants can bid up on up to three
homes each week
um and for those that aren't able to
be through the website or the smartphone
app then we can arrange for auto bids to
be set up
where we have parameters of what kind of
properties that they would be
interested in being considered for and
then bids could be placed automatically
on their behalf
and i would stress one of the myths
around devon home employees
home choice is that bidding involves
partying with money
there is no money involved all bidding
means is it someone is simply
registering their interest
in a property bids can only be placed
once an application has been assessed
and activated and the reason i mention
this
is quite often we have people contact us
because they're not registered on devon
home choice but they suddenly become
aware of a property becoming available
that they'd like to be considered for
and quite often the problem with that is
their application won't be activated in
time for them to place a bid
so i would always encourage people if
they think that they have a housing need
that they register on application
rather than wait until there's a
particular property that they would be
interested in
applicants can usually only bid on
properties that match their household
need
so when an application is assessed it
will give a banding
and a bedroom size of what type of
property that they will be considered
for
so someone who's got a one bedroom need
would not normally be able to
bid on two or three bedroom properties
hawkins can you answer that one no
please yes certainly
uh thank you um yeah i was just curious
as to
uh are we as counselors able to set up
our own
and bid on behalf of somebody if they
they have difficulty sort of accessing
things
um if you have the consent of that
individual
it may be possible yes but
generally that there's quite an onus
then on you looking every week
and taking on that responsibility so my
advice would be that
where there is that kind of need that we
look at setting up an auto bid
so that people don't miss out the the
follow on question then would be i think
you said that they were
limited to three at a time
yeah three bids per week so should i
find myself in a situation where i've
got more than
maybe two or three people and i wouldn't
then
would have set up nine bids a week three
for each for example
sorry like for example if i had three
people that asked me to um help them
find something
um and i wanted to set up three bids
for each of them oh yeah that would then
be nine beds
i'd take it i wouldn't be able to do
that with a beat comes through their
application
so it's three bids per application so
the fact that you were placing those
bids
wouldn't matter thank you
and the other thing that i would mention
is
that um through devon through devon home
choice the aim is to try and
promote that people can move around
devon if that is their wish
but obviously we don't want any district
any one district to be burdened by that
so the numbers moving in and out of each
district through devon home choice are
monitored
to make sure that they balance so that
the number of moving in
balances with the number of moving out
over the course of the year
and to achieve that there may be times
where
the borders to a particular district are
closed
and what that means is that more people
have moved into that district from other
areas
than than has been expected and
therefore the borders are closed
to enable priority to be given to those
with a local connection to the
particular district
so it always ensures that there's a
balanced approach
if we can move to the next slide please
so at the end of the advertising cycle
it is the actual landlord of the
property that produces a shortlist
um and the applications are prioritized
by
banding and the length of time an
application has been in a particular
band
so what that means in effect is that the
applicant in the highest band for the
longest period
will be the top of the shortlist and
then what happens
starting at the top of the shortlist the
landlord will carry out
the verification checks so they'll check
that all the information contained
within the application is correct
and they will also speak to
the applicant about any history around
rent areas
anti-social behaviour whether the
applicant is likely to
be able to afford the property and to
make sure
that all the details of the application
match to the requirements of the
property
um and then if uh
there's what i would say then is the
applicant who
is successful is likely to be the
applicant who is at the top of the
shortlist
but there are on occasions reasons why a
landlord may
skip applications if they believe that
the applicant
doesn't meet the requirements for the
property what i would say
around this is that devon home choice
has its own um
policy but in addition each landlord
will have its own allocations policy
and sometimes what you will find is that
there may be a reason that particular
landlord won't accept an applicant so
maybe it was
the applicant was previously a tenant of
that landlord
and caused damage or are left with lots
of renters
and on that basis sometimes we find that
an applicant may be awarded quite a high
banding on devon home choice
but we find a particular landlord may
well skip them for their own reasons
um and what i would say at this point if
there's any queries around
shortlisting skippers skipping or
offers uh not being made it is always
best to direct those to the landlord
because it's actually the landlord that
makes those decisions
rather than housing options at torridge
um
and unfortunately as much as we would
like to have sway over who is it
accepted for each property we don't make
that decision it is
ultimately down to the landlord
so if we can move to the next slide
please
so sorry it's just come up quite small
but this is just some information
around the last quarter of 2020
and the uh properties that were
actually uh offered to applicants
and if you look at the table to the
left-hand side i know there's a way of
making the tables bigger perhaps just
looking at the first one to the
left-hand side first
that's it thank you so this refers to
just general needs homes rather than
sheltered housing um and actually if you
look so over the last quarter
in torridge um there were
26 properties allocated
so i don't know if once you've had a
chance to look at this
table whether there's any questions
around these numbers
i think what i point out at this point
if you look at the number of properties
becoming
uh available relative to the number of
application applicants we've got on
devon home choice
it's very clear that we have to be
honest with people and say that the vast
majority of people
registered on devon home choice at the
moment will not receive
an offer of accommodation through devon
home choice
okay that's pretty stark yeah
i mean that is just the um sort of
last quarter of last year and obviously
last year was a very unusual year in
terms of fewer properties becoming void
but but generally when we speak to
applicants we do try and be as honest as
we can
about saying that demand for social
housing
far far exceeds supply
thank you any questions i see new hounds
yeah
coaster hawkins thank you me again
i'm i'm doing my best to learn all of
this it's become quite relevant very
quickly in recent days
um so what i did notice
again talking to somebody that's looking
for accommodation
um and she's now
shared with me some of the paperwork
that gets put into
to some of these bids uh and then
talking to her
more about things uh what i've seen her
put on a form
when she puts in the bid there are
certain aspects that can be
um we may be able to work on
uh obviously she uh that they've got the
ability to be able to pay
a set amount up front and
uh i think some of the other benefits
she's also
there's a guarantor that that can be
used
um some of these things are
worst case scenario so should she need
a guarantor she could get one
should they need um
money up front to help with
hopefully sort of convincing or swaying
the owner of the property to
to let her rent the place um
she could also get that but the um
what i think i'm trying to ask is
sometimes what's put on the application
isn't set in stone and it's almost like
when i'm trying to help her i could do
with the person coming back to me that
owns a property saying
this doesn't quite fit are you able to
do anything with the amount of money
that
they're able to supply up front um
we we've seen that she may be able to
get a guarantor can you get the
guarantor to come and speak to us direct
and and verify who they are and what
position financially they are
can uh so i'm almost feeling like
given the opportunity to talk to the
owner of the property
we could work something out that doesn't
mean the person i'm trying to deal with
is any more or less um
in need of a solution but i just feel
like from my point of view if i'm able
to
actively take a role in talking with
the owner of the property i might be the
sole problem that i've got with
with a resident whereas at the moment it
just seems like
and i know it's the way that it is a lot
of these people that are needing
needing somewhere to live they're just
chucking their paperwork in and just
crossing their fingers and hoping for
the best
i just feel like i could be doing more
to
accommodate the needs of the um property
are you talking about uh someone who's
applying for
sort of housing in the private rented
sector as well when you refer
when you're referring to guarantors
yeah well yeah they're trying everything
they can
i think with the um that you're trying
to help it may well be worth me
emailing you a link to um our
housing jigsaw system so they can refer
in for some housing assistance from
from housing options and then we can see
um whether we can help them with both
the the search for private rented
housing
and um looking at devon home choice and
seeing whether that is an option for
them
and one of the questions we get asked
quite quick quite often
is well how long will it be before
someone receives an offer of housing
through devon home choice
and that is a really really difficult
question for us to answer
because we never know what properties
have become available through devon home
choice in advance
and additionally we don't know who's
going to bid on each property that's
advertised
so sometimes there can be high demand
for a property
uh so therefore you've got lots of bids
placed but often
for for some times reasons we don't
understand
there might be few bits placed on a
particular property
which means it goes to someone in a
lower band than we might expect
generally i would say to people i would
expect properties to go
to people in band b or c but
there are occasions where people may
well be
successful for a bid on a property and
they are in bad d
it's really difficult for us to ever
predict and i guess
part of what this table does is show
that actually i can say generally
ban b or c but there are definitely
occasions where people in band
will be offered a property so
that's why we would never say to someone
it is not worth them
registering on devon home choice because
it is
because we can't predict what the demand
is going to be for any one property okay
thank you does that answer your question
kosher hawkins
yes i think it's just um obviously we're
we're starting to see
that it's quite a dire situation and um
yeah and uh i'm not sure
i'm not proposing that there's some kind
of way that i
can jump the list i'm just saying that
as it happens
there are so many people trying to get
these housing houses
and somewhere to live
but personally i happen to have one
person
that is asking me for help
so any way that i can um
learn more about all the options that
are available to
to be of help um
you know i'm just a minefield at the
moment
okay can i just say time is going on i
gotta keep an eye to the time i've got
some hands come up here as well so can i
move on to counselor leather his hat has
had that night for some time
and then phil top a more independent
member thanks joe just briefly um
councillor hawkins carl was there
talking about guarantors and saying that
possibly
the private sector where deposits are
required
george are able to help and helen has
answered
some of it there is help available and
i'm pretty sure if helen does send
carl the information that she mentioned
but
torridge can help out with deposits in
the private sector as well
so if i can just respond to that so
where someone is
threatened with homelessness or homeless
certainly housing options can help
with financial assistance which may well
be
deposit or rent in advance if someone
is not threatened with homelessness
but is choosing to move and they are in
receipt
of housing element of universal credit
or housing benefit there is also an
option for them to
apply for a discretionary housing
payment to help cover the cost of
deposit
deposit and or rent in advance so there
are
options available to people if the
barrier to them moving
is um financial thank you
um phil topham thank you chair thank you
helen
uh yeah it looks like a very workable
system to me but i
the bit that sort of i feel slightly
uncomfortable about is the bit where the
landlord is making selections
against criteria excuse me
we sound right on the surface but is
there any kind of check on how they're
doing
it or why they've made the choices there
are is there a kind of feedback loop
between
the client and the landlord and and
different choice about this is it you
know is it sufficiently transparent
i i would say in terms of devon home
choice that
the whole point of devon home choice
said it is a fair and transparent system
which is it why it's so clear with the
banding and that is why
properties are allocated through devon
home choice rather than outside of devon
home choice
in terms of social landlords um
skipping applicants or deciding that
they wouldn't be suitable
tenants they are adhering to their own
policies
and uh procedures on that
so you would think that their boards
are involved in some of those decision
makings
there is an option for applicants to
ask for a review of the decision but in
our experience what we find
is because landlords are under pressure
with their voyage
times what will happen is you can
challenge a decision but they've already
moved on to the next applicant
and are considering the next applicant
for the property
so what you find is yes the decision may
be overturned but it won't mean that the
applicant will get
offered that property because the social
landlord would have already moved on and
offered it to the next applicant
okay thank you that's clear what i would
say is
with housing options where we think that
there may well be an issue with an
application
we will be having conversations with
those social landlords at an early
stage uh to make sure that there are no
last minute decisions
like that okay thank you helen cheers
fire on helen right and
and the next few slides were just giving
a a breakdown
of sheltered housing and also particular
areas
um so we've got the torridge let's but
we've also
got a breakdown of the towns of
biddeford holdsworthy and torrington
so that people can um just see how
properties are there and this is dating
back to 2018 as well
so it's like over the last three years
um
yeah thank you so again it's just
whether
people got any questions around this
information
um the other thing i would point out
regarding this is you will note that we
have very few
wheelchair accessible properties in
torridge
goshens bambi
okay thank you no questions yeah
keep firing if you can please yep
so it again it was just giving a
breakdown of information regarding the
main towns and properties let in those
towns
so what you'll see from that is the vast
majority of properties that become
available
are in biddeford um with fewer
properties available in
torrington and i was worthy
lovely
any further questions one from chris
leather
yeah all the statistics we've seen from
helen can we have those email around to
us please
i'd like to look at them at you know at
leisure and and just
take the information on board please
check there's a huge lot of information
there helen and
um it's um just glazed with numbers at
the moment i have to admit but i
in in the statistics i'm sure there's a
lot of value as questions leather has
just asked you
so thank you for all that okay
uh any other questions
no so can i helen can i thank you and i
will remember
next time
indeed for your your presentation and
your work you're doing it's
it's hard going and it is you know
putting values
to personal situations and i mean we as
counselors like carl as
hawkins has mentioned sometimes come
across some very difficult situations
it's
hard to resolve when you're doing it all
the time you have my admiration so thank
you very much indeed for the work you're
doing
thank you ask us as counselors
from your side of the equation very
briefly because we have a few questions
anything you'd like to say to us
no i've got no questions thank you
you're right you're
you're good thank you very much indeed
thank you
okay thank you then right committee um
as as i s look at the clock it's now
just gone uh four o'clock um i do like
to have some recommendations right but i
am aware of the time
is there any recommendations first of
all yes i wanted to say thank you to
barbara shaw as well she had to lead to
a meeting at 3 30 and
we'll make sure um we thank her for her
presentation from from
westwood is there any urgent
recommendations on the two
two presentations that any counselor
wants to raise and i have counselor
thank you actually it wasn't about i
just wanted to say thank you to
councillor leather
um yesterday i did approach uh
housing options at tdc they were
brilliant
um so yeah but thank you for
uh pointing that out
so okay go back and thank you for that
question hawkins then is there any
recommendations
pressing recommendations or or having
had the information and responses
we have uh from both the presenters of
this
housing issue of from both from westward
and
from the housing options to who's the
other devon home choice
team i take that we will take the
presentations as noted
sorry cursive leather well check yeah
no particular thing for westwood housing
but only that i didn't get an answer
will we get that presentation of helen
sent round
particularly all those statistics we
could do with all i'd like those and
share the story yeah i've sent it to all
councillors
as as counselors so it should be in your
inbox now chancellor lever
but ty reed and chris and
yeah well i might have known that um
there'd be some prompt response
that's brilliant thank you they're
brilliant how good the team are is
fantastic so there we are okay i'm
they're taking us moving forward to our
next item on the agenda
which is the responses that we have had
from
sir jeffrey and you've had a chance to
have a peep of them
um very gracious i i actually enjoyed
reading them
i wonder what your your your comments
were as as a committee
and how you wanted to respond
had that from cursor langford thank you
um just quickly um i asked a question
about the future high streets fund
um i i did feel that it wasn't really
clear because i specifically asked how
much he lobbied on our behalf it wasn't
really very clear how much
he lobbied before the decision was made
and i have actually
um mentioned it to chris um
fuller and uh just for everyone's
interest really he said that um
uh a not very well noticed section of
the leveling up
fund which i think isaac's yard will be
perfect for
includes a line around the mp ultimately
needing to be the individual who backs a
project
and there being an emphasis on one
project per
mp regardless of where he crosses more
than one district
so i thought that might be interesting
just for people to be aware of
and the other thing chris said was he
found his broadband section very
interesting as he is currently exploring
options around precisely that sort of
scheme for local communities to access
rural gigabit vouchers
okay thank you okay
um who is the legal expert can you
advise me um
there was a bit of a thoughtful in uh
government um a couple of weeks ago
about the uh
towns that qualified uh and i think it
was 47 out of 56
um tones were of the red wall
constituencies
but is this the same as the high street
fund can somebody advise me
or have i got that wrong
perhaps you really want me to to come in
put me in there because it was using
slightly different words but it
seemed you're just a concern that um
people had that because jeffrey is such
a strong
mp in torridge um we didn't get the
support if we had been more of a
a balanced uh um uh voting system when
we come to elections basically
i'm not going to comment on the
political side of it but from the
funding side of it and
from following on from what council
langford's just said
yes there are some more funds available
and one of them's a levering up leveling
up fund i i can't
remember off the top of my head the
other fund and i know it's something
that counselor james is working
alongside with steve at the moment
we don't have the 4d okay
details um so as soon as they become
apparent and we're a bit clear on the
bidding criteria
and then we'll be circulating that to
members but we haven't had
the full criteria for yet but there
certainly are lots of different pots
seem to be
be coming out at the moment so similar
to the high streets fund but not quite
so there may be i know there was a bit
of disappointment on on the high street
fund but
going forward we may be able to have
something else and we're certainly gonna
um work towards putting some bids in i
think the bids have got to be in by june
so we've got to act really quickly
um i think part of the good thing about
the future high streets
um part is that a lot of the work's
already been done
so hopefully we can feed off of that to
be able to submit a bid really quickly
all right uh coachella leather
yeah thank you chad yeah i think what
stacey said it the
the leveling up fund that jeffrey cox
mentions there in his uh
leveling up article of 4.8 billion yeah
we we might be able to access some of
that
which is a separate thing to the um
future high streets from
the other thing following on from that
was a future agriculture policy
i was a bit mystified by that opening
sentence i would challenge the
committee's assertion that food is not
considered
to be a public good where did where does
that where does he get that
impression from this committee i mean
i think i don't understand that first
line to be honest okay
i'm putting in the picture i mean i've
had several discussions
with jeffrey um um and and various
organizations and
and when they talk the talk about the
changes under the agricultural bill
the the terms of using land for the
public good food production wasn't seen
to be
one of the one of the public goods it
was changes of use of the land
um from and if you go back
uh many years ago it was miniature
agriculture fisheries and food
and then i went to defra which was
department for the environment
farming enough department of the
environment food and rural affairs
um and there was no even talking in the
future there would be a change from
the situation of food
from that situation so whether that is
influenced that
i gave no impression it was just that
it's been in the press that
it was noted that food wasn't put
forward as the public
could and if you remember michael winter
when we had the
uh adoption of the local power back in
october and 18
talked very much there at westwood hill
if we're at the pier house if you
remember
he talked about the public could and
that wasn't
mentioning food then at the time it was
about access it's about
environmental schemes it's all the other
schemes um
they're equally important um but that's
where the issue came from i think
because of another yeah well the thing
is that through production
and i'm old enough to remember years ago
used to be a strategic priority in this
country it was a strategic
necessity the more food we could produce
here the better
but a government and i won't say what
brand it was but the government
many years ago now decided to downgrade
food production
they said we could always import food
from a board perhaps cheaper than we
could
produce it here it's up here there is
some truth in that i know
but for me food production in this
country has always been
or should be a strategic priority but no
government since then
has ever plastic is a strategic priority
and i've always believed it ought to be
so maybe maybe they will change
the view on that given the level of
discussion i better declare
a member of the national farmers union
and the country landowners association
so i have a personal interest
so i'll just make that clear from that
point of view given the discussion
any other hands going here
no all quiet at the moment well i i was
was very impressed with the with the
the response again jeffrey always does
um put back a very good response to us
so raises concerns um i would certainly
echo
the uh leveling up one that i think
council lang would put forward
and in response i would like um the
committee to agree to thank jeffrey for
his response
and it is desperately needed for some of
our town centers particularly if there's
going to be a large sum of
money going into barnstable um that we
do access some of these funds and we
trust for his support for the future and
i
hope you as a committee would endorse a
comment in that direction in response
whilst thanking him for his responses
here at the present moment
okay could i just chip in there yeah of
course you can coach them
i think it's just worth pointing out
that i agree with you the the
responses are detailed and fulsome and
and
you know knowing jeffrey like you do
that they're fairly straight
um it doesn't point to note that i know
certain members of the committee were
disappointed that
jeffrey declined to turn up in person
um however
i think you can make the point that you
often get a more
detailed and more fulsome response
if actually write to him on paper
because they've got time to actually
research and consider etc as opposed to
seeing somebody in the flesh where you
probably wouldn't have got
half this detail if he was having to
answer off the top of his head
um so actually we may have got better
quality answers by doing it
on paper even though some people may not
have been satisfied at being able to
to to poke him with a sharp stick in the
flesh so to speak
okay cheryl connor honking i got an
email from you but i can't um
i i just if you could expand on what
you're saying sorry
have you finished simon
i i'm serious i have indeed sorry yes i
apologize simon okay
coaster cover honking i i've got a a
cryptic message from you
no i didn't have my hand up that's fine
don't have your hand up okay
okay that was uh dealt with that one any
other comments
then picking up coachella langford's
point about the future high street fun
hannah having missed out
so badly i just wondered if we could not
make a response of thanking
jeffrey for the response and
highlighting the need to work
in detail to secure funds for our town
centers
i wondered if the committee would agree
to that type of response to to what we
have here
can i make another proposition now can i
make that a proposition
to make specific reference film to to um
the leveling up fund as such
and you know i mean he's he's made
reference to the 4.8 billion
um so if we're specifically asking him
to fight hard on our behalf for a
share or a a a share
of that leveling up fund the southwest
being recognized as an area that needs
leveling up just as much as the the
north west and northeast
my concern as coach newton is is that
given that the
fund is going some of the future
actually fund is going to barnstable
the inequality between biddeford and
barnstable will increase in the future
that's my concern unless we secure more
funds and that's what i'm concerned
about i
am in in the light of where we are
economically in relation to the greater
northern devon area
and that's why i would make the
proposition here and know that we
actually
underline the need in the light of the
award to bolster under the future high
street fund
that we do at least get some clear
idea of how to to secure some funding in
the future
yeah yeah yeah so that's my
s that's right uh stacy uh legal
give me some advice yeah it's not not
for me obviously to
to get involved with the proposals that
members make at all but
um it was just to say really that um the
leader and
chief exec are going to be working
alongside jeffrey cox with this and i
think
the idea first of all was to kind of um
finalize the bid that we're gonna be
putting in
um and then liaise with him in relation
to the support
um needed so i was wondering if it would
be better for that that process to be
finalized and when we know what the bid
criteria is etcetera because at the
moment
it's not quite clear and the government
hasn't released all the details
um and i was wondering if it might be
preferable
once we have all the bid criteria we
have our project clear
then to make um uh contact with the
actual specific support we need
um you know what you say um uh
i i think i had council mother's hand up
there just now did i have that correct
or not
yeah you did sure yeah following on from
what stacy said that's fair enough
and and councillor newton mentioned the
4.8 billion leveling up fund
i don't think it's worth rehashing the
future high street fund
application and the fact that barnstable
with their
compared to our scheme second rate
scheme in my view
got some funding we should be
concentrating as stacy's just said
on the leader and and steve
dealing with jeffrey on this leveling up
fund and i think if we make a
recommendation
thanking well we thank jeffrey cox for
sending his response
but we could say we believe that he is
working with
the chief executive and leader of
torridge
and we hope he's using his best efforts
in securing some funding
for the regeneration scheme in benefit
from the leveling up fund
very well put coach leather i will uh
second that if you
oppose that and i will draw my original
proposal i will propose that chair
i have second that is committee happy to
adopt that in that
wording do you have to take a vote stacy
we had a proposing a seconder yes yeah
mary can you take a vote on that
proposal that there's another pencil
there yes sir
councillor hankin
councillor ford council harding
definitely council hawkins
oh councillor langford
four cancel letter
or i think councilman mckenzie's left
the meeting am i right
you slept yeah
councillor newton or councillor
pennington
yeah mr topham for
this unanimous chair thank you very much
mary
okay thank you very much committee any
other comments on that agenda item
can we move on uh please check one if i
may
you know irrespective of of uh
it's a political aspect but the response
from our local mp to our questions
there's quite a bit of material in there
which is of general interest
is there merit in circulating our
questions
and uh jeffrey's answers
around all councillors in the council
just from a general
information point of view
i think that if coasters are interested
they would have followed but if there's
a wish the committee that we do
send them around i know my inbox gets
very full at times and i press
the delete button too often i think
occasionally
yeah it could it could go on the members
bulletin all right then
i'm happy to do that if uh or perhaps
simon
wants it or christian wanted to go
forward which do you feel is committed
i mean i'd have thought that the
bulletin would be fine i i i wouldn't
want to
push it round as an individual thing
because people would then see it as
as me peddling jeffrey cox's stuff which
is not
i'm but i just think there's there's
material there that information there
that
counselors should reasonably be aware of
and have access to
that's right there's an official update
from their local mp that's all
okay so we go for the members bulletin
committee
we ask if the questions and the response
to be placed in the members bulletin
yeah yeah yes do we need to vote on that
one against stacy
yes chair no proposed by councillor
newton seconded by council whether i
take it
putting words into your mouth counselors
is that okay
well you don't like my people putting
words in your mouth phil but
i'll go along with that yeah
i that's i give you a chance to say no
cursor leather i didn't want to
tread on any toes whatsoever i'm too
amenable to say no you know that
okay we have a pros and a second or mary
you know the routine can we go through
the routine to put
the questions and the response
that jeff is so kindly sent forward into
the members bulletin
council or councillor ford
or council harding
council hawkins abstain
pennington mr topham
for chair that's eight forum one of
absention thank you very much counselors
i see
any other comments on that agenda item
before i
press on none good we then go forward to
work that mary has so finally put
together um
the annual report for 2021 which is just
let me make sure which the agenda item
number
is here is number 10 fresh draft of the
annual report so this is the first draft
we have another meeting coming up um
in april so so that i think it will be
our final draft
any comments on what you have here
before you
i'm looking for some hands i got two
hands why can't i see the two hands
tom yeah it's councillor cole honking
and count um
mr tobin right was uh
uh councillor caldwell honkin first then
please
so it's actually um you talk about the
members bulletin i didn't know
it's going back to westwood housing
whether we should put in the um
contacts for the directors she gave us
the
four directors that we could contact
maybe that would be useful for all
councillors
to have committee are you happy that
that could be circulated to all
councillors i take it there will be a
circulation
yeah we can have that chair yeah
are you happy that's dealt with uh
coaster connor hunkin
yeah thank you thank you uh phil topham
yeah thank you chad a couple of things
on the agenda
page 21 um with regard to the annual
report
the top of the page were carried out in
2021
yeah um at the bottom of underneath
those bullet points it said the
committee also considered in depth how
it could improve the quality of scrutiny
and when i read that i thought ah what
did they decide
so i wondered if we could include
the little paragraph from the minutes of
the meeting of july the 20th
which says what we actually did decide
and i've uh
i happen to have it in front of me but i
can i'm i'm sure that mary could find it
i can tell where it is i'm happy for
that to be included because
i have to apologize for you because i
was meant to come back to you
um and i haven't done that this time as
well picking up the comment you're
making
um i'm happy to put a paragraph in there
um that
we because it will come back
ratification
at our next meeting this is just the
first draft
are you happy to put that in mary do you
know that
are we clear about the the paragraph
we're talking about here
yep i think someone from the minutes
here
the minutes of july the 20th and it's
um it's
oh my gosh i've lost it now
it was under our list of priorities and
there's a paragraph which starts on a
more general level
counsellors agreed that it was better to
concentrate on doing a few things well
etc etc
that paragraph yep yeah
okay i'm happy to put that in because i
think that's reflected of the work
program we've had some uh details there
okay this will come back to our next
meeting
um four four rounds it is a draft
situation here
and the other thing we've got
um each as you go through the pages
you've put the
um strategic aims in large font
at the head of some sections and
i wondered whether that actually adds
to the sort of informational value of
the document
that if in fact we wanted perhaps at the
end
to reflect on how our different
presentations had contributed or
reflected
some aspect of the strategic aims could
we put that separately
rather than putting our little reports
of scrutiny meetings under one of those
headings or more
times uh yes explain to me again um
you would take well out the our
requirement as a scrutiny committee to
necessarily
pursue these strategic aims of torres
district council
although we would hope that our
activities are consistent with that
so i wouldn't want to disconnect from it
but i just wondered if at the end we
could put
something which said the the areas which
we considered
fell under these these strategic aims
yeah
because you've got all the forces
cheating aims of the of the council here
a set for customer focused kind of if i
remember rightly we've got three of the
three of the four no sorry you've got
the effective customer focus council as
well so we've got all four there
from so you would take those four
stronger safer healthy communities
prosperous sustainable economy affect
the focus council
what's the other one we've got four all
together got me a fourth one now
the effective and customer focused
council
um what i'm saying is that we could then
reflect on how our activities relate to
the strategic aims
as a separate paragraph rather than
putting a report of our activities under
each of those headings
it's just a different way of presenting
it would that greatly change
the presentation or would that just be
drawing them together at the
end of our work
so if you put it at the end it would
sort of it would
you know it would show again like the
earlier comment in mind about
how we reflect on the work that we do
and how it connects with the
aims of the council so it's not taking
them out it's just putting them
all together position uh comments please
cursor leather
thanks chair well i wanted to just
comment on the bottom of page 21 there
is this link to phil's topham's comment
here at the principal
no can i just stick with him topham's
comment that's a leather just to make
sure
um that we get this question of taking
these bow prints out and put them in a
final paragraph separately that's what
i'm
i want to clear up before we go on to
another issue here
i i agree sorry
uh this is country newton i take it yeah
yeah yeah i
i i agree with with phil topham on on
this
i think the the the eye is drawn
from the actual subject matter of what
we were
we were scrutinizing um and
almost slightly a hijack by the
strategic plan that sort of tried to to
um take precedence so over our subjects
we weren't actually considering the
strategic plan when we actually decided
what we wanted to look at
i agree that actually one paragraph at
the end
demonstrate how our activity
has in ti and places related to the
strategic plan
but doesn't we're not talking ticking
all the boxes but i i agree with phil
in presentationally personally any other
comments contrary to
to phil topham and coachella newton
i said i i listening to the comment i
would go with that as well
mary can you make that over alteration
do we we don't have to vote on that
stacy do we
no problems with that right any further
comments i have
sorry because the leather again is that
casual leather
yes thank you yeah the bottom of page 21
outcomes
i realize this is a draft document at
present but i mean
recommendations we make i'd like to see
in the outcomes
whether they're acted upon or not
because i'm aware that our
maintenance budget the player is was
refused
not accepted at cnr but it has gone to
internal scrutiny i think
for reconsideration but i mean the
outcome should say
not just what we've recommended but what
effect they've had whether accepted
or not and the other one was the public
participation bit where it mentions
about the palladium club in biddeford
um i don't know whether we ought to be
mentioning him by name or not ben nye
um but as my member served me correctly
that was about
because he was talking about supporting
the plow
and we have a service level agreement
with the burton art gallery
which is a separate thing because we own
the burton um
i think when he came and spoke to us it
was on whether there's any funding
available
from torridge directly that could help
with the palladium
and you and you you and the vice chair
did visit and i know
quite a lot of strong well a lot of
support was
spoken
outcome question marks well i think we
ought to put something in there that
unfortunately you know so we need to
mention
that unfortunately we weren't able to
you know
include there's no funding available
otherwise every every club in the area
or every
would be looking so we ought to put
something in there about the area
if we change that final paragraph around
to say
um i think ben and i was the only public
participant
um that we had on external throughout
the
last 12-month period um so so
so we could actually turn it around to
say well
we would have wished more public
participation um
where there was public participation we
got involved um
but again we are only competition to
take too long now to do that but i am a
bit nervous from from
from highlighting that situation um
and a better way of just saying that i'm
taking out
the palladium club and ben nye because i
think you are
you know bringing a situation there
forward in that way
um any inspiration from anybody just at
the present moment
yeah you've got councillor carl honkins
hungary's how's your call honking
um i was just gonna say that we did
actually because we went
um along with some of the ward members
and asked him to present to full council
but we didn't hear any more from him um
but i don't know if you want to take out
the name and everything on the
public participation part we could just
say that we have
one member of the public participate
that's right let's turn around and say
we had some public participation
in which the committee tried to follow
up and offer assistance
and welcome public participation into
the future
and it takes out the outcomes at the
present moment but this is something
about
welcoming future public participation
when it's read
when when our issues come along um and
then it takes out that ben nye
situation i i wonder if you would agree
with that change of termination at that
point
your say you mentioned about members of
the public are welcome
to attend any of the overview and
scrutiny committee meetings okay
we'll see we have had some presentations
during the last
12 months leave it at that you know let
me do a draft because it is still draft
it comes back to you to change it again
at the next meeting um can i
work on that with mary to put something
in there reflecting our discussions
now this afternoon
yes or no committee
i would put something together um
with mary so it comes back um to this
committee at the next meeting is that
okay
am i dead have i died here yes it's okay
yeah we all agree with you chair we all
agree with you
we just like listening to you
faces it's just
that's where i breathe thank you for
that i thought i've
i crashed out okay are you happy yes
right that will be done from that point
of view
any more on the um um
annual report i see no hands going
so we'll work on those points put that
together
and come back then hopefully you can
choose a paragraph for the final draft
then um at the next meeting
thank you for that next we go on to
the forward plan
now then we have um the floor plan i see
that
it takes us up into
um is it the 20th of april 20th of april
28th 28th of april just let me get my uh
downloaded a copy i've got another copy
here
uh with the uh date on it now we've got
um petroc coming to that
situation i just wondered if we
wanted to put some questions together
again prior to that meeting to send to
remind me of um petra sean mckechnie
isn't it have i got the right
pronouncing
pronunciation
yeah anyway it's the head of pet
droplets coming to us do we want to put
some questions together
for for this meeting
yeah i think that's a good idea do we
need to be meeting or can we forward
those questions
to uh mary to ford
for pacifica we do do we do you want
another meeting house we had
for for for this meeting or or or can we
do it by email to mary
um uh to put the questions
of what we specifically want it is
promoting youth employment
and there's some dire statistics coming
out about youth employment
uh there may be specific questions about
apprenticeships or
training schemes that you want to ask
do you want a specific meeting phil
topham
yeah thank you chad this is not so much
about questions to ask
sean mcnay but questions which he asked
us at his presentation
um because i don't think it was entirely
rhetorical but at the end of his last
presentation
he said what do you want from petroc and
what opportunities do you see for petroc
and i wasn't aware that we in any way
answered those questions
for him and i wonder if that might be an
interesting starting point
and also showing that we do listen to
him
good point coach uh phil topham
so perhaps we can um answer that
question when we put the points to him
of uh other responses we make from that
point of view uh particularly bear in
mind
um do torrents do any youth training
schemes do we
do what level of uh
response uh stated do you know we have
with
with the pet rock i know do we have a
board member for instance on pet drop at
the moment
i'm not sure if we do now we certainly
did
and what i can say is that we do work
fairly closely with petroc
um and the apprenticeship scheme um that
comes through
um quite often they go to petrol can do
the the courses i mean it's not my
expert subject it's it's sara
but we certainly do uh work quite
closely with them on the apprenticeships
and also petrol often come in um and do
trade
with george okay then maybe if we put
that as one of our questions
sorry who's that i can't see
well i think i don't know if we need to
put a list of questions to him
for the meeting it's it's really for him
to give us a presentation
i take what phil said about he asked us
questions what do we want from better
i'd rather hear what he's offering the
district and
particularly around promoting youth
employment and yeah we do have
apprentices at torridge
and i'm very interested in the they've
had a lot of success i think
petrakov with apprenticeships and really
i think it's for him
to give us a presentation he he's coming
to speak to us about what petroc do
and particularly around youth employment
and i don't know
whether petra involved with that new
business innovation center that the
county have built
on the roundabout at roundswell there if
they got a link up with that or not
um i would have thought they would have
but i don't know so really
i just say we want a presentation on the
work that petroc do
particularly around youth unemployment
is there any country views to that
there's no pressing you would want from
that is phil topham
yeah i wonder if a useful starting point
might be his last presentation which i
think would be available to us
um bearing in mind that he had then been
in post for just about
six months so it would be interesting to
look at that and perhaps sort of take it
on from there
because i'm sure his views will have
changed and circumstances have certainly
changed
all right secretary um so
how would that's what what question
would you be asking him
preparing for the meeting coming forward
how would you
well i would be asking him you know what
has changed what has stayed the same and
what has developed since you last spoke
to us what a year ago
and what you know what are the key
burning issues in
furthering higher education and
employment at the moment as he sees it
well i think that's just as wide as what
we've actually got on our forward plan
at the present moment promoting
youth employment which is you know a
quite a dire situation
um i'm you know again go back to the
comments
uh uh about preparing for the meeting
scoping for a meeting
if there is something burning that you
want to put in
then i'm happy for the
question to be put forward and if you
want to put that forward
then please do and i'm happy for that to
go forward
is the question in preparation for the
presentation the 28th of april
um yeah one of the things we could ask
for is any statistics that he was going
to present at this meet at this
meeting in april that we get them ahead
of the meeting so we can
look at them and you know around youth
employment and unemployment
and youth education at petroc and what
they've been doing
i take phil's point about 12 over 12
months ago since
and he hadn't been in pulse very long
then accordingly
to what phil says so any statistics he
wants to present
us with we i'd like them ahead of the
meeting then we can study them
right then we can certainly request that
phil i don't know if you can prepare
your question in the way you want
to prepare that question and we can get
that forward to him in preparation
for the 20th of april i have two or
three questions i want to certainly put
in i don't know if anybody else wants to
put any questions in
princeton yeah i just thought it was
um
[Applause]
it was a good idea to have some
questions because last time we had
presentations there were complaints that
it wasn't um
structured enough and that we needed to
be more
um detailed and what we wanted so all
i'm trying to do is
what the committee races concerns after
the
uh cabt tvs and encompass meeting
so i'm i'm making sure that we prepare
well
um so if you want to send your questions
in
send them to mary and go from there
i'm no looking at the time it's 1643.
um please keep brief if you can i don't
want to call past three hours again
coaching langford just just um can we
have a date
to get these questions in by that's all
yes nate
i mean there's nothing to stop us again
as soon as possible today is the 10th of
march
can we get them in by the 20th of march
to give them
give some chance for for um
the the presenter to put the
presentation in response to them so
20th of march questions into mary
is that okay committee good
no hands up that deals with that one
we've got also some gaps coming up now
i got two meetings i think it's the 28th
of may and the 21st of july but it's not
actually shown on our sheet
um here do you want to start populating
those dates which is in the new council
year
we have phil topham
phil topham oh you're muted sorry
um i should know this from past
experience but
will there be a change in the committee
structure after um
after april after the committee
membership
as i understand it there will be an agm
this year
and i it should be that all posts should
go through the election process stacy
will tell me if i'm wrong on this one
uh from that point of view um and since
you've asked the question
and to be totally honest with the whole
committee i will not be taking the chair
of this committee
in the new year i think that scrutiny is
best served
by somebody from outside the need member
party
and there will be a change because i
will not be chair of this committee
uh before the 28th of may so um i i'm
putting my resignation in
uh i i'm not i'm not my resignation i
put in my stat i'm not i'm
not standing because i i do believe that
scrutiny should be that way so
answer your question phil there will be
a change
uh on this committee on the 28th of may
and there may be changes across
committees
um as every atm takes its place
so chad does that mean we can make some
drafts of such
suggestions but they might be modified
when the new committee comes in
bear in mind yes that's right we i mean
i i do not like tying the hands
particularly of a new kind
with a full plan ahead of us but if you
wanted to put something in
um i just wondered if you want to be
prepared to be thinking about a theme
for i think it's the 28th of may
is the committee meeting that is
scheduled for that period phil topham
yeah well it was about picking up on
what we had to cancel before we were
going to invite the biosphere
and some of their friends and relations
and
bearing in mind that there's now been
declared a climate emergency
would it be a good idea to think about
having them back
as a starting point strangely enough you
should say that one because one of the
big discussions we've been having
um particularly within within the
council is that
it's the environment that that is is is
here and it links into councillor ford
there at westwood
at ecuador i shouldn't say west virgo
because chrysler ford will be really
annoyed at me if i say you say
westwood ho um you know there's been a
large discussion about
the torridge and all the other areas
we've got the biosphere
and all the other organizations and i
wonder whether we could not look at a
themed day around the environment
i don't know how picking up phil
topham's comment has anybody
got any better suggestions for that
let's go oh i got one hand from council
another
yeah well it is one of our
strategic aims is a quality environment
in there
that's right i think the concerns if you
look over the back of the
of the sheet that we've been presented
with housing developments and water
runoff that is a big issue with some of
the sites in our district
overflow issues at apple door and
westford hall
uh surface water draining and flooding
water quality and sewage
and again the aomb biosphere
there that down there and the
environment agency
uh devon county councillor of the flood
authority and southwest water
i don't know if we could have all those
because it would be a very long meeting
if we did
but i think if we made the meeting
around the environment of our area
and involved our organizations
that we work with um to inform us make
that the central
theme of our meeting yeah
any other suggestions
oh chair because the thought here yeah
all right actually yeah i think on board
that very important issues and council
ever has picked on that as we got
australian self with flowers using
everything and we have got a look at um
going forward because
again we all know that we are both
agricultural area fishing but
also more importantly probably tourism
and we have got triple r
aside a bit rare we got to talk about
biosphere
but quite frankly because we haven't and
we'll acknowledge that got the
resources to manage things at sea or
whatever
but it's a big issue because you've got
the tall and torridge history
so going forward i think this topic
may need discussion or even a joint
meeting
sometime in the future with north
seventh district it needs a proper look
at this it's a serious big topic going
forward
and with that i'll leave it it's only a
suggestion
good point councilman ford
we can always invite a joint meeting
with it is an evening meeting
that's uh it's scheduled that i see it
um
we can always invite north devon to join
us
on that point as well
a chair yeah uh again you're absolutely
right
and what is saying is it is as phil
tobin said you know it's gonna be very
important but
what i'm being brutally honest about
here
is it might be better putting that one
back a bit further and
at least communication with north devon
it's a big issue right there
because it's getting more usage which is
great you've got
you've got and i'm not going to win the
details of what's been kicking off
recently i'm not interested in that
but going forward you've got a lot of
different users out there wanting ever
we do know it's a lovely area but it is
a bit ironic that it is a triple ssi
biosphere areas as well you see so it
needs a lot a lot of intelligent
conversation here
and less people being personal about
certain users it's great to see it used
safety issue i've got issues obviously
on land with safety as well as on the
slipway that's irrelevant
but it's a big big discussion needs to
be out and i'd rather
be deferred a little to get more
information and join together
with our associates fellow members at
north seven whether i'll leave it
well bear in mind that we are now
talking about the 28th of may
which is no more than
[Music]
yes 17 or 18 weeks away um
um i don't want to lose you know
this situation can we put that as our
theme
with an invitation to north devon to
join us in this discussion
i think i think chair some of the some
of the
contributors to that like in devon
county council or the environment agency
southwest water they'd be much more
likely to come to a joint meeting of
both councils scrutiny committees
than than you know and it would serve
the purpose
our biosphere and our
our environment covers all northern
denver not just torridge it it is all
right
okay let's turn it around the other way
then um we've seen as it is
into the 28th of may can we make some
enquiries
in the meantime and report back to our
28th of april meeting
or is that too late i think it is too
late we need then something else to go
in here for the 28th of may
is there something pressing that you
would like to deal with
on the 28th of may if we're going not to
deal with the environment
as a committee
you have the list of various items at
the bottom of the page
and um i don't want to go past the three
hours because
we just started four minutes past two so
uh i can go to four minutes past five
which gives me 14 minutes but
i don't check sorry yeah chair i don't
know if there's any
a point in putting something in there
from about leisure services i mean with
obviously by then um we would hope that
torridge
pool would be open and there might be
some
i mean i don't know if we're going to
get feedback obviously we'll get
feedback to full council about the
situation with the
leisure services but i don't know if um
it would be
pertinent to put it on the scrutiny
meeting for then i don't know
dory sorry uh coach langford stacy
no it's fine and council langford's
already made the point it is full
reports coming to full council shortly
um or on but
if you reminded you you could have it
depending upon what
what the outcome is then so um we'll
give be able
we're compiling the report to give
members full details
shortly so i think there was talk of a
potential extraordinary
meeting but i'm not sure that's been
agreed yet
yeah the chair there are a couple of on
the health and well-being
i would be interested in together is the
one that at the top of the list
drug and alcohol commission service and
lisa domestic violence commission
support services
um i think domestic violence
unfortunately
during this lockdown period has been on
the increase
i i think a presentation to us of both
of those would be very
worthwhile does that not link into
the uh crime in uh
cps um janet's gone though um
williams um with the one billy ford
approach of one thing another
is well i i'd like to hear from both
those whoever they are together and lisa
okay there is phil topham um
i'm claire hodgson i'm back sorry
i left you for another meeting and i
didn't switch off
um you were still talking i couldn't
believe it
i don't know you may have well in my
absence uh covered this but
we've had the presentation from westwood
housing because it is our main
social housing provider but there are
other
um social landlords providing pockets of
accommodation who might be looking
or with encouragement uh increase their
development within our area
so would it not be pertinent to look at
uh the properties we let through
choice-based lettings from the range of
landlords and invite some of them to
your meeting
right thank you for that plans because
we always concentrate on westwood but
they're not the only
provider in the south west bill topham
thank you yes um it's really supporting
councillors leather's proposal we're
just sort of
broadening out a bit sort of mental
health and well-being
post covid about which we're beginning
to hear more and
maybe we'll we maybe it's time to start
having some discussions about that
shall we make some attentive inquiries
then that we look at the
the mental health the addiction for
services and put the theme around the
stress
that's been brought about by covered and
make that the theme of
the meeting for may
with reviser that we try to get
something jointly with north devon on
the environment
later on
right we've got two or three choices i
need some clear guidance about what you
want to do guys do we go down to further
housing line
anybody in favor please show
i don't see any hands coming up we've
got
council leather's proposal um and
linking it together with
phil topham about mental health and uh
together the drug and alcohol commission
service lisa
etc those in favor and let me show
yeah count me as well coaster forward
because the ford
i'm getting on with that
and we've then put back the environment
issues to to the uh
work on coming together on the joint
meeting
yeah cause i think that will take time
chair i appreciate that
okay we'll do that then so i'm putting
the proposition forward then that we
make the 28th of may
a meeting that looks at the mental
health involving together in nissar
which is on the health and well-being
emphasis of our committee
and certainly the uh
health we invite somebody from from from
health on
on the mental health side um but we also
invite somebody from the third sector
together and nissar
um to come to that if you're a greek
committee
is there a secondary i'll second it
right
that's good any any uh votes
do we have to vote mary or stacy
no i think we've anybody sure they
disagree with that course of action for
the 28th of may
please show i see no hands
shout now that will be on the forward
plan then for the 28th
of may we will work out this 21st of
july
at a future meeting yeah anybody else
want to say anything for the end of this
meeting
very much we started four minutes late
so it's only two minutes if
two hours of 54 minutes so far
minutes left no no hands well i really
thank all of you for what i find
has found a really useful meeting
actually in in many ways so thank you
all for your work
thank you thank you
thank